ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU
[inaudible]
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
[inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY.
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
XENA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON [inaudible]
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
REYES REVISE RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE
[inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inadible]
WALDRON WEBER WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY TODAY MEMBERS
PLEASE COME TO THE FORE
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER [inaudible]
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND BOB OSHITA
REPETITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I LIKE TO SHARE ONE OF MY
FAVORITE STORIES ABOUT THE WELL
KNOWN MOM SHE NINE WHO LIVED
EIGHT HUNDRED YEARS AGO IN JAPAN.
SHE NINE EMBODIED THE VIRTUES OF
UNDENIABLE HONESTY AND HUMILITY.
ALTHOUGH CONSIDERED ACCOMPLISHED
BY HIS TEACHER MASTER WHEN AND
DEEP WITHIN.
SHE NINE WAS CONFUSED.
IN PERSONAL DESPAIR.
HE WENT TO HONE IN AND ASKED HIS
TEACHER.
WHAT SHALL I DO WITH MY LIFE?
OPPONENTS RESPONSE WAS ONE THAT
HAS QUIETLY GUIDED MY LIFE FOR
ALMOST FIFTEEN YEARS. ONE IN
REPLY DISHING NONE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO DO.
IS TO LIVE YOUR LIFE WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE.
HE WENT ON TO ADD.
IF YOU CAN'T LIVE SUCH A LIFE IS
A MONK DO IT AS A LAYMAN.
IF YOU CAN'T LIVE IT AS A LAYMAN
DO IT AS A MONK.
IF YOU CAN'T LIVE THE LIFE OF
GRATITUDE ALONE.
THEN DO IT WITH PEOPLE.
IF YOU CAN DO IT WITH PEOPLE.
LIVE SUCH A LIFE ALONE.
IF YOU CAN STAY IN ONE PLACE
LIVING WITH KINDNESS THEN MOVE
AROUND INTO IT.
IF YOU CAN DO IT MOVING AROUND
DIDN'T STAY IN ONE PLACE.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT AND MOST
ESSENTIAL.
IS TO SIMPLY LIVE YOUR LIFE WITH
CHIU KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE.
SHE NOW KNEW THAT DEEP WITHIN.
HIS NATURE WAS IN CONFLICT WITH
THE PATH OF TRADITION.
HOWEVER HIS TEACHER HONAN HAD
THE CONFIDENCE TO TRUST HIM TO
RESPOND HONESTLY TO HIS OWN TRUE
NATURE.
HOLDEN WAS INTERESTING SHE NON
DEFINED HIS OWN PATH.
SINGLE PATH TO FULFILLMENT.
SHE NOTS LIFE OF KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE.
NATURALLY GREW FROM HAVING HIS
LIFE GENUINELY FULFILLED.
WHEN THERE'D BEEN TIMES OF
CONFUSION IN MY LIFE?
THIS STORY HAS COME TO MIND.
AND I'VE BEEN ME TO REMEMBER
AGAIN.
THAT WE MUST FIND THE COURAGE TO
BE OUR CHIU SELVES.
AND FROM OUR GENUINE FULFILMENT.
A LIFE OF KINDNESS INGRATITUDE
WILL FLOW.
NOW MORE MEDIA WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AS HE LEADS US.
IN THE PLEDGE MISTER GLORIA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLACE
YOUR RIGHT HAND OF YOUR HEART
READY BEGIN.
JEFF BRIDGES TO THE FIRE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY
THIRTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN EASILY
MET SANAM I WILL KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF BECKY DOT THE
HOLES AT THE DESK.
REQUIRE KATHLEENAND LUIS
READING THE ROLL WAS CALLED
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THERE ARE NO ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS QUIRK SILVA AND LOW TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS.
ON THE FLOOR TODAY MISTER LOW'S
GAS WILL BE SEATED IN THE AREA
OF THE MEMBERS DESK. FOR THE
LGBT PRIDE MONTH CEREMONY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA IS
GAS WILL BE SEATED AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE ALLOW SOME
THE MEMBERS OBERNOLTE.
YOU GARCIA LACKEY AND FONG TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER TO
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE
S. B. SIX FORTY ONE LARA.
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE AND SP A
TWENTY THREE HILL FROM THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW COULD COMMITTEES TO
NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
PENDING RE REFERRAL. TO ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO
SET A S. S. B. A TWENTY EIGHT
WIENER S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE
AYE CASKEY AN SP SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE WINNER PENDING RECEIPT
RECEIVE FROM HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPED COMMITTEE.
SP TWELVE FIFTEEN HERTZBERG
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
AND SP TWELVE SIXTY JACKSON
PENDING RIGHT RECEIVED FROM THE
NATIONAL RESOURCE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HEARING ON WEDNESDAY JUNE
TWENTY SEVENTH TWO ALLOWED
ACCOUNTABILITY IN MINISTRY
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO SET S. B.
THREE C. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN GLAZER.
FOR THEIR WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY
SEVENTH HERE BOB LET COMMITTEE
AND TO ALLOW THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE TO SET.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY THREE
PORTANTINO FOR THEIR TUESDAY
JUNE TWENTY SIX HEARING.
PENDING RECEIPT FROM THE WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
TODAY.
MEMBERS OF YOUR ALLOW ME I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY COUSIN MARY
DAHLSTROM ENTER TWO SONS CLAYTON
AND JEFFREY.
DAHLSTROM WHO JOINED US IN THE
GALLERY WELCOME
.
TO MEMBERS I AM GOING TO AGAIN
RECOGNIZE MISTER CALDERON. FOR
HIS PROCEDURAL MOTION MISTER
CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENSUS WENT
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO A
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTED HERE S. B. THIRTEEN ON
JACKSON.
AT THEIR WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY
OF HEARING.
MS WALTER FOR PURPOSE.
WE OPPOSE THE MOTION THEN AS FOR
ROLL CALL MISS WALDRON IS
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
THIS IS A RULE WAIVER MISTER
CALDERON MOVES WE HAVE A SECOND
BY MISTER BONTA.
ON THE SUSPENSION OF THE RULES
MEMBERS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLL MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISS WALDRON AND NOW MISTER
VOTE.
MISS WALDRON A NO VOTE
[inaudible]
IT TAKES [inaudible] FORTY ONE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL EYES FORTY SIX
KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MS AGUILAR CURRY FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SOMETIMES WE WE DO THESE --
HON ELSE WITH A PICK OUR FRIENDS
IN THE GALLERY THEIR VERY
MEANINGFUL IN THIS ONE IS VERY
SPECIAL TO ME.
TODAY I RISE TO RECOGNIZE DIXON
HIGH SCHOOL MIGRANT EDUCATION.
DEBATE TEAM FOR WINNING THE
STATE CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE
SPANISH DIVISION IN CALIFORNIA'S
ANNUAL SPEECH AND DEBATE
TOURNAMENT.
THE TEAM INCLUDED SENIOR JUAN
CARLOS CHAVEZ SANTOS WHO WILL
ATTEND CAL BERKELEY IN THE FALL.
SOPHOMORES JOSE HERNANDEZ A LOT
CALLING HIM TO HERNANDEZ INS AND
JOSE SANTOS AND FRESHMAN.
AMY CHAVA SANTOS.
EVERYONE OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE STRAIGHT A STUDENTS EVEN
THOUGH THEY SPEND HOURS EVERY
WEEK SINCE DECEMBER PREPARING
FOR COMPETITIONS.
THEY WERE MENTORED BY THEIR
POACHING ADVISOR SERGIO LUNA.
ASSISTANCE COULD SHE THINK
ORACLE NO LOPEZ AND MARIA
HERNANDEZ.
AND I ALSO WOULD GOOD SHOUT OUT
FOR MY GODSON THE SUPERINTENDENT
NICK JR MONTY.
THE TEAM'S COACHES AND PARENTS
ARE WITH US TODAY IN THE GALLERY.
THESE KIDS GIVE ME SO MUCH HOPE
FOR THE FUTURE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THEM FOR THE TERM
TREMENDOUS.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THANK YOU PICKED.
MR HOLDING YOUR RECOGNIZE A
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M.
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO STAND
HERE TODAY TO WELCOME MY A
DISTRICT DIRECTOR --
CATHERINE DEL ROSARIO AND MY
FIELD REPRESENTATIVE FAITH LEAD
WHO ARE HERE OF WITH OUR TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN YOUNG
LEGISLATORS WHO REPRESENT MANY
OF THE CITIES IN THE FORTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
SINCE JANUARY THEY HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN PUBLIC POLICY.
AND LEARNING A LOT ABOUT HOW
THIS INSTITUTION WORKS AND
THEY'RE HERE TODAY TO CONCLUDE
THEIR SIX MONTH PROGRAM AND WE
WANT TO WELCOME THEM HERE TODAY.
AND JUST KNOW THAT OUR FUTURE IS
IN GOOD HANDS WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE THIS SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE FORTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT YOUNG
LEGISLATORS. FOR THIS YEAR.
AND MR MEDINA FROM MISTER
CALDERON STANCE MISS MEDINA YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I LIKE TO TAKE THIS
MOMENT TO INTRODUCE.
THE SIXTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
DISTRIBUTE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
YOU THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN BEYOND THE CLASSROOM.
AND AS A FORMER EDUCATOR I KNOW
HOW VALUABLE THAT IS.
STUDENTS WITH GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS
LIKE THESE STUDENTS ARE HERE ARE
THE VOICE OF THE YOUTH.
AND MAKE AN IMPACT ON THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM STUDENTS
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
STATE GOVERNMENT AND THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THESE STUDENTS ARE THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW ONE OF THEM WILL BE
SITTING HERE.
IN MY SEAT SUNDAY.
I AM VERY PROUD TO WELCOME TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
SIXTY FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
YOUTH ADVISORY COUNCIL WELCOME
AND PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN WELCOMING.
AND MS QUIRK SILVA YOU HAVE
GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM VERY EXCITED TO
INTRODUCE MY FAMILY THAT IS HERE
TODAY AT MY DESK I HAVE MY
NEPHEW SAM.
J. SO WHO IS GOING TO BE A
JUNIOR AND SAN DIEGO BONITA HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS
I HAVE MY OTHER TWO NEPHEWS A
MOSES J. SO.
AND JAKE UP JAY SO MY SISTER LA
NET J. SO AND MY MOTHER JOEY
THEY'RE HERE FOR A FEW DAYS TO
LEARN ABOUT WHAT I DO OUT HERE
IN THE CAPITAL.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM RE REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
I DO NUMBER SIX AB FORTUNE OF
SIX GLORIA TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
AND ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BERMAN TO
THE ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE
.
AND MS BAKER MS BAKER HAS GAS
MEMBERS.
IS BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
MEMBERS IN THE SUMMERTIME --
MANY OF US WELCOME IN TERMS TO
OUR OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THEY
LEARN GREAT SKILLS IN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE PUBLIC
SERVICE UP CLOSE AND TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TO YOU.
A COPIER KATIC DADA FROM --
PLEASANTON AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTEEN SHE'S A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT WHO'S JOINING US TODAY
PLEASE WELCOME OUR SHE'S UP WAY
FAR IN THE GALLERY OF THEIR
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL AND TRANSGENDER PRIDE
MONTH.
WE WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX THAT IS HR ONE OH
NINE BY MR LOW. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THIRD READING MR LOW ARE YOU
READY TO PROCEED ON THIS ITEM.
YES MISTER SPEAKER THE CLERK
WILL READ HR ONE OVERNIGHT.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE NO NINE BY
SILLY MEMBER LOW AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
AND TRANSGENDER LGBT PRIDE MONTH
[inaudible]
MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO INTRODUCED
HR ONE ZERO NINE WHICH DECLARES
JUNE AS PRIDE MONTH.
EACH YEAR JUNE MARKS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE STONEWALL
RIOTS THAT GIVES BIRTH TO THE
MODERN.
LGBT CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
CALIFORNIA AND ITS DIVERSITY IS
ONE OF OUR STATE'S GREATEST
STRENGTH.
TODAY OUR LEGISLATURE IS
REPRESENTED BY THE LARGEST LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA COMPRISED
OF EIGHT OPENLY LGBT LEGISLATORS
THE MOST AND ANY STATE HOUSE IN
THE NATION.
THE LP COMMUNITY HAS COME A LONG
WAY IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
THAT WASN'T ALL THAT LONG AGO WE
WERE HERE FIGHTING IN CALIFORNIA
AGAINST PROPOSITION.
EIGHT THE PROPOSITION THAT
ELIMINATED THE RIGHTS OF SAME
SEX COUPLES TO MARRY.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY.
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA A FIRM
SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT TO MARRY REGARDLESS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR GENDER.
A GREAT AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
INDICATE THAT THEY WERE FIGHT
HAVING SAID THAT THIS IS NOT
TRUE.
JUST THIS MONTH THE SUPREME
COURT RULED IN FAVOR.
OF A BAKER WHO WOULDN'T MAKE A
CAKE FOR A GAY COUPLE.
TODAY WE ARE HONORING SIXTEEN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ON A DAILY BASIS
[inaudible]
FIGHT EVERY DAY. FOR EQUAL
RIGHTS.
THEY ARE ACTIVISTS.
ARTIST CULINARY EXPERTS ELECTED
OFFICIALS CEOS LEADERS AND ROLE
MODELS.
THEY RANGE FROM ONE SPECTRUM TO
THE OTHER BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
THEY ARE HUMAN.
WE ARE PROUD TO HONOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS TODAY.
ON YOUR DESK YOU WILL NOTICE A
BAG WITH A LAPEL PIN.
SKITTLES A PINWHEEL AND A NOTE
INSIDE. 40% OF HOMELESS YOUTH
IDENTIFY AS LGBT.
THIS YEAR THE CAUCUS HAS
PURCHASED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
BACKPACKS.
STARTING TODAY WILL TAKE THESE
DONATIONS TO FILL THE BACKPACKS
WITH ESSENTIAL NEEDS FOR THOSE
LIVING WITHOUT SHELTER.
WE ARE INDEED LEADERS OF THIS
GREAT STATE ACCEPTANCE OF ALL
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY
SHOULD BE SOMETHING AS THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE ALL STRIVE.
FOR I STAND HERE PROUD TO
INTRODUCE HR ONE ZERO NINE AND
DECLARE JUNE AS LGBT PRIDE MONTH
AND HOPE YOU'LL JOIN.
ME IN DOING SO AS WELL.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE THE FIRST ROLE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE MISTER
BONTA S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIKE THE NO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR ONE NO.
NINE THE CALIFORNIA LATINO LGBT
COMMUNITY ENCOMPASSES A DATA OF
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL LATINOS
REPRESENTING THE GREAT
EXPERIENCE AND DIVERSE CITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
LATINOS ACROSS EVERY MAJOR
SECTOR IN OUR STATE SOCIAL
FABRICS ARE PROVIDING A POSITIVE
INFLUENCE FROM ACTIVE MILITARY
SERVICE TO PUBLIC SERVICE OR
SUCH AS SEAN'S AS CORPORATE AND
NONPROFIT BOARD ROOMS.
LIKE YOU KNOW HOW TO BE T.
INDIVIDUALS ARE ACTIVELY
ENGAGING IN LEADING A NEW AGE IN
CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP.
THEY EXAMPLE FLY THE TRUE NATURE
OF SERVING OUR COMMUNITIES WITH
DISTINCTION AND WITH HONOR.
MANY AS YOU CAN SEE WHO ARE PART
OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY HAVE
ADVOCATED ACROSS BOTH LATINO AN
AGILE LGBT COMMUNITIES THEREFORE
I AM PROUD TO STAND.
ON BEHALF OF LIKE YOU KNOW
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN ASKING
YOUR SUPPORT ON H. R. WHAT NO.
NINE THANK YOU MISS CERVANTES
MISTER GIPSON YOUR RECKON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE.
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS -- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HR ONE OH NINE
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INFECTIOUS DISEASES
IN HIGH RISK DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
PRIDE HAS PRIDE HAS STORIES
HISTORIES.
OUR THAT MANY HAS FORGOTTEN IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE MARSHALL
PETE JOHNSON.
A BLACK TRANS WOMAN STOOD UP
WITH THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY BY
FIGHTING UNJUST POLICE
HARASSMENT AT THE BAR IN.
GREEN WHICH VILLAGE HER ACTIONS
BEGAN THE STONEWALL RIOTS WHICH
DURING THAT DAY.
WAS A BAD SITUATION BUT HER
LEGACY WILL BE ATTACHED TO THE
PRIDE.
THEY'LL GB TQ COMMUNITY.
HISTORY SHOWCASE NUMEROUS OF
BLACK A KNEW WAS A BLACK
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LED THE
EFFORTS OF CHANGE YET PEOPLE WHO
IDENTIFY AS BLACK LGBTQ.
STILL HAVE A HARSH REALITY.
THAT THEIR FACE WITH.
IMPORTANTLY THEY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
AMONG THOSE LIVING AND DIAGNOSED
WITH HIV AND AIDS IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE BLACK LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND ADDRESS THIS
UNIQUE CHALLENGES.
THAT THEY FACE.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT. TO NOTE
THAT WE HAVE COME ALONG WAY YET
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO SO
DURING THE PRIDE MONTH.
WE JOINED OUR COLLEAGUES TO
CELEBRATING THE ACHIEVEMENTS OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AT THE
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO ACHIEVE IN OUR QUEST FOR
EQUALITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RELIABLE.
OR HR.
ONE OH NINE THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON MISTER LEVINE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT.
OF COMMEMORATION OF PRIDE MONTH
AND THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
FROM EUREKA TO SAN DIEGO FROM
COASTAL TOWNS TO DESERT CITIES
CALIFORNIANS ARE.
OPENLY LOUDLY AND PROUDLY
CELEBRATING WHO THEY ARE JUST AS
IT SHOULD BE IN SOME OF THAT WE
SHOULD BE CELEBRATING. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS A FEW WEEKS AGO.
WE ARE HONORED THE MEMORY
RECOGNIZE THE MEMORY OF HARVEY
MILK WHO WAS A ROLE MODEL FOR
THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
AND THE LGBT JEWISH COMMUNITY
AYE IN CALIFORNIA AND TODAY LGBT
RABBIS LEAD CONGREGATIONS
PROBABLY OFFICIATE SET SAME SEX
WEDDINGS.
AND WORK WITH TEENAGERS WHO ARE
DEALING WITH COMING OUT IN
EDUCATING THEM I CALIFORNIA AND
LGBT T. COMMUNITY WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER.
ON THESE ISSUES AND TO CELEBRATE
PRIDE AYE URGING AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MICHELINE.
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THINK IT WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR ONE
OH NINE IN BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS REPRESENTING THE EL OF
THE LGBT.
OF MANY OF US CROSS REFERENCE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT CAUCUSES AND A
LOT OF WOMEN WHO ARE LESBIANS
STILL CONTINUE PEOPLE ARE OFTEN
SURPRISED TO CARRY ON SOME OF
THE SAME TRADITIONAL ROLES AS AS
EVERY OTHER WOMAN.
AS CAREGIVERS AND THOSE ANTS WHO
ARE ALWAYS THERE TO TAKE THE
KIDS SOMEWHERE WHEN THE PARENTS
ARE TOO SAD AS THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE PARENTS WHO MAY BE
SUFFERING FROM.
ALZHEIMERS OR DEMENTIA OR
WHATEVER IT IS THAT WE ARE
OFTENTIMES ARE NOT THE ONES WITH
CHILDREN WHO ARE OFTEN THE ONES
WHO ARE STEP UP TO BE CARE
GIVERS.
THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT HISTORY
AND AND CERTAINLY TODAY NOW WE
ALSO KNOW AS WOMEN THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT THE ISSUES OF
NOT HAVING THE SAME RIGHT FOR
PAY.
THE SAME ISSUES AROUND
HARASSMENT THAT WE'VE HAD
HISTORICALLY FOR WOMEN IN
GENERAL BUT THAT'S ANOTHER LAYER
WHEN YOU ADD ON LGBT COMPONENT
OF THIS SO AS PART OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE ALSO SAY
WHEN WE HAVE OUR OUR RECOGNITION
OF PRIDE MONTH.
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION ALL THE
DIVERSITY THAT WE REPRESENT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
ALL DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
HAVING CEASED.
THE AUTHORS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
CO AUTHORS ON THE H. R. ONE OF
NINE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON H. R.
ONE OH NINE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR AUTHOR FIFTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS ADDED IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE LGBT CAUCUS.
WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
WELCOME THE MANY SPECIAL GUESTS
WHO HAVE JOINED US TODAY.
AND ARE SEATED THROUGHOUT THE
CHAMBER.
EACH YEAR THE CALIFORNIA LGBT
CAUCUS HONORS INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
I AM APPOINTING AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE TO BRING OUR SPECIAL
HONOREES ON TO THE FLOOR FOR A
SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETIRE TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AS I CALL
YOUR NAME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BERMAN
[inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FREEDMAN
[inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GLORIA BECAUSE FLETCHER.
AND MS IRWIN.
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF MEDINA
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
RAY S. [inaudible]
RE BASS [inaudible]
AND RUBIO.
AND OUR GUESTS FROM THE SENATE
SENATORS GALGIANI [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
AND WIENER.
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON
REPUBLICAN LEADER BRIAN DALLY
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI
ATKINS.
ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT CAUCUS CHAIR
ADVICE YEARS EVAN LOW.
AND RICARDO LARA HAVE MOVED TO
THE CENTER AISLE TO ACCEPT OUR
HONOREES.
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO THE
INTRODUCTIONS OF THE LGBT PRIDE
MONTH HONOREES.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THE
CLERK WILL READ.
HONOREE LA DON BEST IS ESCORTED
BY SIMPLY MEMBERS CERVANTES AND
O'DONNELL.
MYTH LA DON BEST JOINT PEER
HEALTH EXCHANGE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR LOS ANGELES.
SHE JUST BUNDLE FOR DEVELOPING
MANAGING GROWING AND EVALUATING
PEER HEALTH EXCHANGE LA.
SHE LEAVES HER TEAM GUIDES THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IT RAISES
FUNDS AND PROVIDES FISCAL
OVERSIGHT.
EMPIRE POSITIONS LADONNA
ASSISTED LGBTQ SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND TRADE
SERVICE PROVIDERS ON THE
BARRIERS FACED BY LGBT Q.
SURVIVORS SHE ALSO SERVES AS A
GIRL LEADERSHIP COORDINATOR FOR
REACH LA WELCOME LADONNA BEST
.
HONOR WE HEY BIOLOGY AND IS
ESCORTED BY SOMETHING MEMBERS
EIGHT MEN AND GABRIEL.
MR HAY EGGPLANT YET IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE GAY AND LESBIAN
ARMENIANS SOCIETY.
TODAY THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
PROMOTES THE QUALITY OF HEALTH.
HE ARMENIANS AND SEEKS TO BUILD
BRIDGES WITH ARMENIAN AN
INTERSECTIONAL COMMUNITIES.
MR BIOLOGY AND WORKS AS AN
ADVISER TO THE CHILDREN OF
ARMENIA FUND AND IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARE
BUT FOUNDATION FOR FILM MUSIC
ARE.
WELCOME MISTER HAGUE PLAY AGIAN
.
HONOR WE PAY AND AND CHEN
INSTITUTION CITY OUT HER SCORED
BY SENATOR GALGIANI [inaudible]
FOR BLOOM.
AND CHEN AND CINDY POWER THE
FOUNDERS OF BLING BLING DUMPLING.
THE PARENTS FIRED BY HAND MEET
STREET FOOD FROM THEIR HOME
TAIWAN.
THE MERGED THEIR FAMILIES
RECIPES WITH INVENTIVELY
OFFERINGS TO CREATE THEIR
POPULAR AND CREATIVE DISHES.
THE RESULTS OF MANAGE TO WILD
VEGANS AND OMNIVORES ALIKE.
LING LING DUMPLING HAS GAINED
NOTORIETY ON THE CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WILL CIRCUIT AND HAS BEEN
PROFILED IN SEVERAL LA AREA
MEDIA OUTLETS WELCOME IS AND
CHEN AND MISS IN THE HOUSE
.
HONOR WE OTHER TILL CORTEZ IS
ESCORTED BY SOMETHING MEMBERS
GLORIA AND RELAX.
MR A BOTH TO CORTEZ HAS BEEN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MAMA'S
KITCHEN A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
NUTRITIONAL SERVICE TO PEOPLE
CRITICAL ILLNESSES INCLUDING HIV
CANCER HEART FAILURE AND
DIABETES.
ALMOST NINE MILLION MEALS HAVE
BEEN DELIVERED TO SAN DIEGO
COUNTY RESIDENTS.
THIS NAVY VETERAN HAS BURKE IN
THE FIELD OF HIV EDUCATION
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
THAT INCLUDES SOME OF THE VERY
EARLY HIV PREVENTION EFFORTS
TARGETING LATINO COMMUNITY.
COLOR WELCOME MISTER OTHER TO
COURT HAS
.
HONOR ETIRI CUNNINGHAM IS
ESCORTED BY SENATOR WIENER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
TERRY CUNNINGHAM HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN FIGHTING THE AIDS
EPIDEMIC IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
EIGHTY TWO WHEN HE FOUNDED THE
CHURCH HERE MEMORIAL PLANET.
TODAY IT IS THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY PROVIDER OF HIV
SERVICES THAT COUNTY.
HE IS ALSO CHIEF OF THE HIV S.
T. D. AND HEPATITIS BRANCH OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES FOR THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM SHARED HIS
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ON HIV AND
AIDS IN THE U. S. AND ABROAD AND
IS RECOGNIZED AS ONE WHO HAS
MADE SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE GAY RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN
THE U. S..
WELCOME MISTER TERRY CUNNINGHAM
.
HONOR REVENGE KILLING HAND HAS
REPRESENTED BY HIS KNEES SKY
FERREIRA.
SHE IS ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS GLORIA AND REYES.
THE LATE THEN DON'T HAVE WITH
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
POLITICAL POWERHOUSE IN HIS
SECOND CAREER THEN BECAME CFO
FOR THE SAN DIEGO METROPOLITAN
TRANSIT DEVELOPMENT CORD.
AFTER RETIRING FROM THE MARINES
MAYOR MARINO CONNOR TAPPED HIM
TO BE HER CHIEF OF STAFF.
DEALING AND BECAME A WELL
REGARDED BIGGER POLITICS AND
HELPED FOSTER THE CAREERS OF
MANY LGBT POLITICIAN.
WELCOME ENTERING ITS KNEES
MISGUIDED CRAP
[inaudible]
HONOREES.
WHERE THEY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES AND?
FOR SUSAN DUNLAP AS THE
PRESIDENT AND C. E. O. OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES
THE CENTERS PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE AND
SEXUALHEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
SEX EDUCATION TO SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
DUNLAP IS ADVOCATED FOR LGBTQ
ISSUES LED EFFORTS TO DEFEAT
ANTI CHOICE BALLOT MEASURE
CALIFORNIA REBRANDED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD THROUGH.
SPANISH PUBLIC EDUCATION PASSED.
IN PROVIDED LEADERSHIP TO
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILY PLANNING
PROVIDERS WELCOME MISS SUSAN
DUNLAP
.
HENRI MICHAEL FLEMING IS
ESCORTED BY SENATOR WIENER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
MICHAEL FLEMING IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DAVID THOUGH
THAT FOUNDATION.
HE'S WORK TO IMPROVE SOCIETY
BICU SOCIAL JUSTICE LGBT
ISSUES IN THE ARTS GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND PROGRESSIVE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
WITH A BACKGROUND IN BROADCAST
MEDIA AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS
PLUMBING ITS HELP STEER OVER ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SHARE THE
FOUNDATION'S VISION.
UNDER FLEMING STEWARDSHIP THE
FOUNDATION ESTABLISHED AND
FUNDED LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AT SOME OF THE
COUNTRY'S TOP SCHOOLS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE.
WELCOME MISTER MICHAEL PLANNING
.
HONOREE STEP GRANT IS ESCORTED
BY FAMILY MEMBERS CERVANTES AND
IRWIN STEP GRANDSONS AT THE TOP
OF THE AGENCY THAT SPECIALIZES
IN LGBT WEDDINGS AND CORPORATE
EVENTS.
SINCE LGBT AFFIRMING WEDDING
PHOTOGRAPHERS ARE DIFFICULT TO
FIND STEPHANIE THAT SHE COULD
HELP LGBT COUPLES BY CAPTURING
THE BEAUTY OF THEIR LOVE AND
HAPPINESS ON FILM.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN SHE
PHOTOGRAPHED THE FIRST LESBIAN
INDIAN WEDDING IN THE U. S. AND
CONSIDERS IT SOME OF HER
PROUDEST WORK.
ORIGINALLY FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH
GRANT FOUNDED THE PROMOTE LOVE
MOVEMENT WHICH PROVIDES A SPACE
FOR PEOPLE TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES IN A JUDGMENT FREE
ENVIRONMENT.
WELCOME IT'S STUFF GRANT
.
HENRI DANIEL PENNY IS ESCORTED
BY SENATOR WIENER AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
DANIEL HANDING HIS LGBT THEATER
OWNER WHO FOUNDED THE BLANKS
YOUNG PLAYWRIGHTS FESTIVAL THE
ONLY PROFESSIONAL NATIONWIDE
COMPETITION FOR PLAYWRIGHTS
IGNITES.
NINETEEN TONY AWARD WINNER
STEPHEN PARA IS A THREE TIME
YOUNG PLAYWRIGHTS BEST WILL
WINNER.
HENNING HAS BEEN AN ACTIVIST
SINCE MIDDLE SCHOOL HIS RECENT
WORK FOR LGBTQ EQUALITY INCLUDES
CREATING THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF LA BLACKOUT
PROTEST THE FIRST MAJOR LGBTQ
DEMONSTRATION IN THE U. S. WHICH
PREDATED STONE ALRIGHT BILLION
BY TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
HENNING HAS WRITTEN DEVELOP AND
PRODUCE MANY PLAYS ABOUT THE
LGBTQ EXPERIENCE AND REYES
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR LGBTQ
CAUSES HIS ONE OVER TWO HUNDRED
AWARD IN RECOGNITION OF HIS WORK.
WELCOME MISTER DANNO HENNING.
HENRI GHENT FUMES IS ESCORTED BY
SOME THE MEMBERS EIGHT MEN
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THE ENVELOPE JUSTICE JIM HUMES
WAS APPOINTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
COURT OF APPEAL IN.
TWENTY TWELVE THE FIRST OPENLY
GAY PERSON TO BECOME A PILOT
JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY HE
IS A PRESIDING JUSTICE.
HIS CAREER BEGAN IN THE COLORADO
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE HE
LEFT OF THE STATE PASSED THE
AMENDMENT.
TO HE ALSO IS CHIEF ASSISTANT
FOR THE CIVIL DIVISION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CHIEF DEPUTY
FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL BROWN AND
GOVERNOR BROWN'S EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY FOR LEGAL AFFAIRS
ADMINISTRATION AND POLICY.
WELCOME THE HONORABLE JIM HUMES
.
ENRIQUE PHYLLIS JACKSON IS
ESCORTED BY SENATOR GALGIANI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
PHYLLIS HAS BEEN ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF SAN DIEGO PRIDE
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN AND IS
CURRENTLY CO CHAIR.
SHE WORKS FOR HOUSING INNOVATION
PARTNERS AN AGENCY WHICH PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR THE MENTALLY ILL.
HER INVOLVEMENT IN MUNICIPAL
CIVIC AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE TOO NUMEROUS
TO LIST.
PHYLLIS HAS RECEIVED THE BAYARD
RUSTIN LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT
AWARD THE EDU AWARD FOR LGBT
CONTRIBUTION IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND MANY
OTHER ACCOLADES.
WELCOME MISS PHYLLIS JACKSON
.
HONOREE KATE KENDALL IS ESCORTED
BY SENATOR WE HEAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
K. CANDLE NEEDS AND ACTS AS A
PRIMARY MEDIA SPOKESPERSON FOR
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR LESBIAN
RIGHTS.
LEGAL ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
ADVANCING THE CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS OF LGBTQ PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES THROUGH LITIGATION
PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCACY AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
THE CENTER ONE THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT CALIFORNIA MARRIAGE
EQUALITY CASE AND AS PART OF THE
TEAM OF ATTORNEYS TO SECURE
NATIONAL MARRIAGE EQUALITY.
LAST AUGUST QUE AND OTHERS FILED
A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT'S TRANSGENDER MILITARY
BAND.
SECURED A PRELIMINARY INJUNCTION
WHICH BEEN TO THE BATHROOM
MOVING FORWARD WELCOME ESCAPE
CANDLE
[inaudible]
ENRIQUE SCORED BY SELLING
MEMBERS GLORIA AND RICARDO
GARCIA.
DEBRA MARTIN IS THE C. E. O. AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR ALL THEIR
HELP AN ORGANIZATION WHICH
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR SENIORS.
UNDER HER LEADERSHIP AS BECOME A
LOCAL AUTHORITY ON AGING AND HAS
CREATED SUCCESSFUL
COLLABORATIONS WITH SEVERAL
LOCAL AGENCIES AND POSITIONS
GROUP.
MARIN IS A FREQUENT PRESENTER AT
CONFERENCES AND FORUMS ON
SENIORS AND AGING AND SERVES AS
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN DIEGO
SENIOR ALLIANCE WELCOME MISS
DEBRA MARTIN
.
HENRI THEORY MCBRIDE IS SCORED
BY SOME THE MEMBERS CERVANTES
AND BERMAN.
SARAH MCBRIDE IS THE NATIONAL
PRESS SECRETARY FOR THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CAMPAIGN AND AN AUTHOR.
ZERO MADE NATIONAL HEADLINES
WHEN SHE CAME OUT AS TRANSGENDER
WHILE SERVING AS STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT AT AMERICAN UNIVERSITY.
SIR ALSO BECAME THE FIRST OPENLY
TRANSGENDER PERSON TO ADDRESS A
MAJOR POLITICAL PARTY CONVENTION.
WHEN SHE SPOKE AT THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION IN PHILADELPHIA
WELCOME MISS SARAH MCBRIDE
[inaudible]
MMHM
.
HONORING HE SAID LITTLE TEN IS
ESCORTED BY SENATOR WIENER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
THE SENTINEL TEN WAS ELECTED TO
THE PALM SPRINGS CITY COUNCIL IN
NOVEMBER.
TWENTY MISS NELSON IS ALSO THE
FIRST TRANSGENDER PERSON ELECTED
TO A NON JUDICIAL OFFICE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S MILTON RETIRED AFTER
SERVING THIRTY SIX YEARS WITH
THE STATE COMPENSATION INSURANCE
FUND OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AT HER RETIREMENT SHE WAS THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS WITH EXECUTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR INTERNAL
AUDIT FRAUD INVESTIGATION PUBLIC
RECORDS AND GOVERNANCE WELCOME
MISS LISA MIDDLETON
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE BEEN JOINED.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY BY SOME
FORMER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HONOR BILLS
YVONNE BRATHWAITE BURKE.
WHEN MORE?
HILDA SOLIS AS WELL AS DELAYING
EASTON LET'S WELCOME ALL OF THEM
[inaudible]
BACK
MEMBERS ROUTE.
SONNY MOTION DAY THE HONORABLE
SONNY MOTION THEY ANSWERING.
EVERY TIME WE HAVE OF THE CHAIR.
MR LOW AND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT CAUCUS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION ATTENTION
TODAY AS OUR GUESTS ARE
EXCEEDING THE CHAMBER PLEASE
JOIN ME IN ANOTHER ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR ALL OF OUR HONOREES
.
MEMBERS ONE MORE INTRODUCTION
THE HONORABLE BONNIE LOWENTHAL
JOINED IT HAS JOINED US IN THE
CHAMBER.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR SPECIAL
CEREMONY.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
AND NINE SIXTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE
.
MEMBERS WHERE BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
FILE ITEMS FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN WILL BE
[inaudible]
CONTINUED
.
MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE THIS IS A CHART
NINETY WINE BY MR MCCARTY.
THE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY ONE BY FAMILY
MEMBER MCCARTY FELL TO THE WORLD
REFUGEES DAY.
MR MCCARTY YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT HR NINETY ONE
RECOGNIZING THIS WEEK IN JUNE
TWENTIETH. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AS WORLD REFUGEE DAY WORLD
REFUGEE DAY IS A GLOBAL EVENT
RECOGNIZED BY THE UNITED NATIONS.
AND HONORS THE COURAGE OF THE
WOMEN MEN AND CHILDREN THAT
BELIEVE THEIR COUNTRIES DUE TO
VIOLENCE PERSECUTION WAR AND
NATURAL DISASTER.
I WILL NOTE TODAY AS A
RECOGNIZED WORLD REFUGEE DAY WE
ALSO LOOK INWARD AT OURSELVES.
AND QUESTION OUR MORALS
REGARDING IMMIGRANTS SEEKING
REFUGE AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE KNOW THAT SOME OF THE SAME
WOMEN AND CHILDREN TODAY BEING
SEPARATED AREN'T BACKED BY
DEFINITION.
REFUGEES FROM CENTRAL AMERICA
JUST LIKE THOSE OUR COUNTRY HAS
WELCOME FROM THE DECADES PAST.
INDIVIDUALS FROM COUNTRIES LIKE
SYRIA IRAQ EL SALVADOR COLUMBIA
UKRAINE BOSNIA AND RWANDA.
OFTEN THESE HEROIC INDIVIDUALS
AND COUNTER HARDSHIPS SEPARATION
EVEN DEATH. TO BUILD A BETTER
LIVES BUILT BETTER LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR CHILDREN.
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW WAS NO
STRANGER TO THIS CRISIS WE'VE
SEEN IN RECENT YEARS A REFUGE --
INFLUX OF REFUGEES HERE IN LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO IN SACRAMENTO.
THIS OF COURSE IS AFTER THE WAY
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AFTER
THE END OF THE VIETNAM WAR.
LATER CENTRAL AMERICA AND RUSSIA.
ALSO VERY PROUD THAT MY CITY
RIGHT HERE SACRAMENTO IS THE
NUMBER ONE RESETTLEMENT CITY FOR
REFUGEES AND SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
VISA HOLDERS IN THE COUNTRY.
AND REMIND YOU THAT THE SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA HOLDERS ARE THOSE
WHO SERVED ALONGSIDE OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE MILITARY --
TO PROTECT OUR OUR MINUTE OUR
SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
FIGHTING FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THIS MEASURE REFLECTS THE
COURAGE UPON THOSE THAT FLED THE
COMPASSION TO THOSE TAKES THE
MEN AND REAFFIRMS OUR OUR
BIPARTISAN COMMITMENT TO HELP.
THE MILLIONS OF REFUGEES OR
DISPLACED --
ACROSS THE GLOBE THROUGH WAR AND
PERSECUTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING HR
NINETY ONE RECOGNIZING JUNE
TWENTIETH IS WORLD REFUGEE DAY.
AND I ASKED THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN TO CO AUTHORS MADE A FEW
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY MS CARILLO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS IN SUPPORT
OF HR.
NINETY ONE IN THE MILLIONS OF
DISPLACED PEOPLES OF THE WORLD
TO SEEK SAFETY AND A BETTER LIFE.
S. THIS RESOLUTION NOTES
CHILDREN ACCOUNT 451% OF THE
REFUGEE POPULATION IN THE WORLD.
WHICH IS WELL OVER SIXTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIA AND AMERICANS ACROSS
THIS NATION.
ARE VERY CONCERNED OVER THE
CURRENT HEARTLESS POLICY OF THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION.
IN THE SEPARATION OF CHILDREN
FROM THEIR PARENTS WHEN THEY
COME TO THE U. S. SEEKING
[inaudible]
REFUGE SEEKING ASYLUM.
THE REFUGEE CRISIS DOES NOT
EXIST OUTSIDE OF THESE BORDERS.
IN IS NOT ONLY SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS IN OTHER PLACES ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT HERE.
FROM THE MEDITERRANEAN CRISIS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE DYING EVERY
SINGLE DAY IN THE MEDITERRANEAN
SEA. TO OVER TWO THOUSAND
CHILDREN.
THAT HAVE BEEN SEPARATED FROM
THEIR PARENTS RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE OF OUR ADMINISTRATION'S
POLICIES.
THESE ARE CHILDREN WHO WERE
LIVING IN CAGES WHO ARE REFUGEES
TO THIS NATION.
WHO ARE NOT ALLOWED TO BE
[inaudible]
COUNSEL FOR SOLD WHO HAVE BEEN
SEPARATED FROM THE ONLY FAMILY
THAT THEY'VE EVER KNOWN.
THIS IS A REFUGEE [inaudible]
DAY.
IN WE HAVE A CRISIS ON OUR HANDS.
AND HOW WE RESPOND AS AMERICANS.
HOW WE RESPOND AS THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY?
SAYS A LOT ABOUT OUR VALUES.
I'M SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION
AND I THINK ALL OF US SHOULD.
BECAUSE THIS IS AN INTOLERABLE
PRACTICE.
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS IS NOT ONLY CRUEL BUT IS
INHUMANE.
IT IS AN ABUSE TO CHILDREN.
IT IS ALSO ACCORDING TO THE
UNITED NATIONS.
A SEVERE VIOLATION TO CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS AND INTERNATIONAL LAW.
FAMILIES ARE SEEKING ASYLUM FROM
COUNTRIES THAT ARE WORN TORN AND
FILLED WITH VIOLENCE.
WE MUST TAKE THE STEPS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WHO ARE LEFT WITH NO
CHOICE BUT TO RISK THEIR LIVES.
IN SEARCH OF A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY [inaudible]
HOW THAT?
IN THIS COUNTRY.
I'VE SHARED MY STORY OVER AND
OVER WITH MANY OF YOU PERSONALLY
AND ON THIS FLOOR [inaudible]
I MYSELF.
I'M AN UNRECOGNIZED REFUGEE FROM
A COUNTRY FILLED WITH VIOLENCE
AND WAR.
AND I'LL GET TO SIT HERE AND SAY
THESE WORDS [inaudible]
AND NO.
BUT THERE ARE [inaudible]
THOUSANDS.
A LITTLE BOYS AND GIRLS UNDER
THE AGE OF FIVE WERE LIVING IN
CAGES AT THIS MOMENT.
IT IS NOT A FOREIGN CONCEPT.
THE SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
RIGHT HERE.
IN OUR HOME.
IN OUR OWN COUNTRY [inaudible]
SO PLEASE.
I ASKED THAT YOU LOOK DEEP INTO
YOUR HEART.
RECOGNIZED THAT THIS IS MORE
THAN JUST A RESOLUTION.
AND THAT WE MUST DO SOMETHING.
TO ENSURE THAT THIS COUNTRY AS
ONE OF OPPORTUNITY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE.
THE GROUND THE SOIL AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING MY VOTE
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS KOREA MISS
GONZALEZFLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THINK ILL I HAVE RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION I WANT THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD IT WAS THAT TIMING THAT
STRUCK TODAY AS WORLD REFUGEE
DAY.
I'M BUT I REPRESENT THAT
COMMUNITIES CITY HEIGHTS WHICH
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES AND IN CALIFORNIA
AND IN OUR NATION.
I'M.
BUT IT'S POIGNANT THAT COMES
TODAY.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMIND FOLKS THAT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT OUR BORDERS.
IS HAPPENING [inaudible] TO
REFUGEES.
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING WHEN
PEOPLE COME TO THIS COUNTRY IN
PRESENT THEMSELVES FOR ASYLUM
THAT IS A LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THAT IS WHAT OUR LAW ALLOWS THEM
TO COME WITH THEIR FAMILY AND
PRESENT THEMSELVES INTO ARGUE
FOR REFUGEE STATUS IT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY AND AS
THEY DO WITH THEIR CHILDREN ARE
BEING RIPPED FROM THEM.
AND BEING PUT IN CAGES.
AND THE PEOPLE REPEAT.
THESE CHILDREN AWAY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO EVEN HUG THEM WHEN
THEY'RE CRYING CAN YOU IMAGINE
IN AN INSTITUTION TWO YEAR OLD
CHILDREN CRYING THEMSELVES TO
SLEEP WITHOUT EVEN BEING HUGGED
BECAUSE THESE ARE NOT MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
THIS IS HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY
TODAY.
IT IS NOT A LAW THAT WAS PASSED
THIS IS A NEW.
IT IS WRONG IN ON WORLD REFUGEE
DAY IF WE CANNOT ALL EXPRESSED
OUTRAGE.
ABOUT THE WAY THAT OUR COUNTRY
IS TREATING FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN.
BUT SPECIFICALLY.
BECAUSE I NEVER WANT TO JUST
HEAR SOMEBODY BROKE THE LAW I
THINK THAT'S IT.
IRRELEVANT DISCUSSION ANYWAY BUT
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REFUGEES IN THOSE SEEKING ASYLUM
THEY DIDN'T BREAK THE LAW.
THE IN FACT WINS BY OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS THEY ARE LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND TOLD THEY ARE
DEFINED AS REFUGEES ARE NOT.
JUST WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
TODAY BECAUSE THERE'S NO BETTER
DAY THAN TO CELEBRATE WORLD
REFUGEE DAY.
AS SO MANY OF THESE CHILD
REFUGEES ARE LEFT ALONE IN CAGES
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY ON THIS
VERY DAY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT VOTE.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER BUT I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR BRINGING THIS.
RESOLUTION FORWARD.
AND I WILL ECHO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO.
ABOUT THIS DAY BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD --
YESTERDAY.
I LIKE MANY OF YOU HERE.
FATHERS SPENT THE DAY WITH MY
SON.
AND WE SPENT THE SUN CELEBRATING
FATHER'S DAY.
YESTERDAY IN LOS ANGELES
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
MORE IMPORTANT TO ME.
THAN MY OWN TWO CHILDREN.
AND AS I CELEBRATED FATHER'S DAY
YESTERDAY I DID THINK.
EARLY IN THE MORNING I WATCHED
THE MORNING NEWS PROGRAMS.
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT THESE
CHILDREN.
ON OUR BORDER.
HOW THEY ARE BEING SEPARATED
FROM THEIR PARENTS AND I THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT AS I CELEBRATED
FATHER'S DAY?
SO I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
AND TO REMIND US THAT THE UNITED
NATIONS HAS SAID THAT THE
PRACTICE OF SEPARATING CHILDREN
FROM THEIR PARENTS IS A HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATION.
AND I COULD NOT SIT HERE THIS
MORNING.
WITHOUT RISING.
SPEAK AGAINST THE PRACTICE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SEPARATE
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS SO I
ENCOURAGED ALL OF US. TO SPEAK
OUT AGAINST IT AND TO VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA DOCTOR
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOUR SPEAKER I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO
ALSO GIVE OUR STRONG SUPPORT TO
HR.
NINETY ONE AND WE KNOW REACHED
WORLD REFUGEE DAY AND WE'VE
TALKED A LOT IN THIS BUILDING IN
AND ALL OVER THE PLACE THAT WE
CAN BE COMPETITIVE IN THE GLOBAL
ISSUES.
BUT WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF IT
HAPPENING RIGHT HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY IT BRINGS IT SO MUCH
CLOSER TO HOME.
WE KNOW IN THE LAST SIX WEEKS
OVER TWO THOUSAND CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN TAKEN FROM THEIR PARENTS.
AS A CROSS IN THIS COUNTRY.
SOME WHO WORK IN THE PROFESSION
OF SOCIAL WORK FOR LAST TIME I
CAN TELL YOU ONE OF OUR NUMBER
ONE POLICIES IN THE U. S..
IT'S NOT SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM
FAMILIES.
EVEN SITUATIONS SOMETIMES FROM
ABUSE SOMETIMES NEGLECT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING. FOR THAT FAMILY UNIT AS
WELL AS FOR THOSE CHILDREN THEIR
STABILITY.
SO AS WE TALK ABOUT THE POLICY
TO DEVELOP IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THAT WE SEE.
THE ANATHEMA OF THOSE POLICIES
BEING ENACTED AT OUR BORDERS.
WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING BUT RAISE
OUR VOICES.
IN DISBELIEF THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING AND IN STRONG
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT THIS PRACTICE
COMES TO AN END.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR.
NINETY ONE THANK YOU DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE AS A
MOTHER TODAY.
AS AN EDUCATOR AND AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF ORANGE COUNTY.
AND AS I SEE NOT ONLY THE PHOTOS
OF THESE YOUNG CHILDREN CRYING
PARENTS HANDCUFFED.
WHEN I THINK OF THOSE IN JUST
THOSE THREE HATS AS A MOTHER A
LEGISLATOR AND AS AN EDUCATOR?
THIS POLICY IS ABSOLUTELY
HORRENDOUS.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT FOR MANY
MANY DECADES THESE FAMILIES WILL
LIVE WITH WHEN YOU UNDERSTAND
THE LOVE OF A PARENT AND NOT
EVEN KNOWING WHERE YOUR CHILD
MIGHT BE.
WHICH HOME THERE AT WHEN THEY
MIGHT SEE THEM AGAIN THIS IS
DAMAGE THAT WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO REPAIR AND THIS
POLICY IS NOT ACCURATE I'VE
HEARD EVERYTHING FROM A BIBLE
VERSE. TWO WE REALLY HAVEN'T
CHANGED THE LAW THIS IS NOT THE
AMERICA WE LOVE AND SO I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
I THINK IT WAS QUIRK SILVA
MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AYE
AYE AYE ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR NINETY ONE AND REFLECT AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
RIVERSIDE DID ON HOW I SPENT MY
FATHER'S DAY.
ARE SO GRATEFUL TO BE THERE WITH
MY CHILDREN.
AND I AND MY FATHER [inaudible]
AND I HAVE REFLECTED AS WELL ON
WHAT WHAT HAS BEEN GOING ON AT
OUR BORDERS YOU KNOW JUST ABOUT
A WEEK AND A HALF AGO --
A NUMBER OF THE CAUCUSES THE
COXES GOT TOGETHER AND DID A
PRESS CONFERENCE.
ADDRESSING THIS VERY SAME ISSUE.
AND I'M LOOK GRATEFUL NOW
CONGRESS IS PAYING ATTENTION TO
THIS THAT THE MEDIA IS NOW
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS.
WE OFTEN SAY THAT THIS TYPE OF
ACT SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM
PARENTS THE WAY THAT WE'RE
TREATING.
IMMIGRANTS FLEEING HORRIBLE.
ATROCITIES IN SITUATIONS IN
THEIR HOME COUNTRIES THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS ON AMERICAN BUT
UNFORTUNATELY.
IT ALL TOO OFTEN IS WHAT HAS
BECOME AN AMERICAN RESPONSE
[inaudible]
OVER GENERATIONS I GOING ALL THE
WAY BACK --
TO LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT A
COUPLE OF INSTANCES IN WORLD WAR
TWO WHERE IF YOU'RE AN AMERICAN
THE PRODUCT OF JAPANESE DESCENT.
THAT.
YOU WERE TAKEN AND AND PUT INTO
INTERNMENT CAMPS THAT.
WHEN REFUGEES WERE FLEEING THE
HELL THAT EUROPE BECAME?
AYE DURING WORLD WAR TWO DURING
THE HOLOCAUST AND THE ST LOUIS
CAME.
FROM YOUR UP TO OUR SHORES.
THAT UNITED STATES TURNED THE
BOAT AWAY [inaudible]
SENDING HALF.
OF THE PEOPLE ON THAT BOAT TO
THEIR DEATHS.
IN THE HOLOCAUST [inaudible]
THAT.
WE ARE SPEAKING OUT NOW ALMOST
FEELING POWERLESS. TO WHAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
AND WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE.
THE WAY THAT OUR COUNTRY IS
PERCEIVED.
AND THE WAY THAT WE TREAT PEOPLE.
AND THAT OF WE HAVE REFUGEES
COMING OVER OUR BORDER THAT WE
SHOULD OPEN UP OUR DOORS THROW
OPEN THE TENT.
WELCOME THEM IN.
FIND OUT FROM WHERE THEY'RE
COMING.
AND FROM WHAT THEY'RE ESCAPING.
AND FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN HELP
THEM.
THAT IS WHAT.
WE SHOULD ASPIRE.
TO AS UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THEY WISH LEVINE MS BAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
GIVE ME YOUR TIRED YOUR POOR
YOUR HUDDLED MASSES YEARNING TO
BREATHE FREE.
IT IS PART OF OUR HERITAGE TO
WELCOME THOSE FROM OTHER PARTS
OF THE WORLD TO COME FROM MUCH
LESS FORTUNATE.
CONDITIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE HAVE HERE AND I DON'T
RISE AS A MEMBER OF ANY
PARTICULAR ONE CAUCUS BUT JUST
AS SOMEONE WHO RECOGNIZES THAT
YEARNING TO BREATHE FREE.
AND SOMEONE WHO IS A MOTHER.
ANY PARENT IN THIS ROOM IN THIS
COUNTRY WE DO ANYTHING THEY
COULD POSSIBLY DO TO GET THEIR
CHILDREN TO BETTER OPPORTUNITY
AND FREEDOM.
WE LIVE IN THE COUNTRY WHERE
THAT IS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
AND IT IS PART OF OUR HERITAGE.
TO WELCOME REFUGEES.
AND TO SET UP A SYSTEM WHERE
THEY CAN LEGALLY CLAIM ASYLUM
AND COME TO THIS COUNTRY AND
WHEN THEY DO.
THEY CONTRIBUTE AMAZING THINGS.
TWO YEARS AGO.
I GAVE A RESOLUTION TO A WOMAN
OF THE YEAR AND I SPOKE ABOUT IT
ON THIS FOOR.
SHE WAS A REFUGEE FROM CAMBODIA.
WHO CAME HERE AFTER BARELY
SURVIVING THE KILLING FIELDS?
SEEN HER UNCLE SHOT IN FRONT OF
HER.
AND COMING HERE WITH NOTHING.
AND SHE BECAME ONE OF THE MOST
CELEBRATED MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY IN LAFAYETTE.
AND WAS RECOGNIZED FOR HER
GENEROSITY HER HARD WORKER
GIVING HER CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
COUNTRY SHE WANTED TO COME HERE.
AND WE HAVE A PROCESS THROUGH
WHICH FOLKS CAN DO THAT.
I WISH IT WERE EVEN MORE OPEN.
BUT NOBODY SHOULD SAY THAT IF
YOU WERE A APPARENT REVIEW
WARRANT YOU WOULDN'T DO
EVERYTHING YOU POSSIBLY COULD.
GET TO THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE SHOULD MAKE IT POSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO COME AND SUCCEED AND
BECOME PART OF AMERICA.
AND THEY ALL SPEAK DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES.
BUT THEY SPEAK A UNIFYING
LANGUAGE THAT WE ALL KNOW AND
THAT IS A YEARNING FOR FREEDOM
[inaudible] FOR OPPORTUNITY.
THROUGH IT AT A CHANCE TO HAVE A
BETTER LIFE AND WE HAVE IT HERE
IN OUR COUNTRY WE SHOULD WELCOME
IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS BIGGER.
MISLIM.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS A FORMER EDUCATOR I
THINK BACK TO HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO KEEP STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO HAS ALSO
WALKED IN A MALL AND SEEN A
CHILD WHO HAS LOST WHO S. PANIC
IN THEIR EYES WHO IS CRANE.
I KNOW THAT THE RIGHT THING TO
DO IS TO REUNITE THEM WITH THEIR
FAMILY.
I CANNOT EVEN BEGIN TO IMAGINE.
WHAT?
CHILDREN YOUNG ADULTS ARE
FEELING AT THIS MOMENT WHO HAVE
BEEN INTENTIONALLY SEPARATED
FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS RESOLUTION THERE'S NO FLAWS.
NO APPLAUSE DURING DEBATE.
IN THE CHAMBER MISLIM ON YOU MAY
CONTINUE.
THIS RESOLUTION IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
BECAUSE SO MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE WITNESSING WHAT
IT FEELS LIKE. TO BE SCARED
[inaudible]
THE PANIC. TO SEE KIDS SEPARATED
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS THAT MOST
MATTER IN THEIR LIVES.
THERE ARE NO SHORT TERM OR LONG
TERMS GAME.
WE ALL LOSE THEIR FAMILIES LOSE
THE KIDS LOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THINK MS ABOLISHED THURMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES ARE RISING SUPPORT OF
HR.
NINETY ONE AND I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I URGE YOU TO DO MORE THAN VOTE.
WE MUST DO MORE.
THEN VOTE.
ON RESOLUTIONS ON THIS FLOOR
[inaudible]
WE MUST.
LIFT UP OUR VOICE. TO THE WORLD.
TO SAY THAT THESE PRACTICES.
CHILDREN BEING SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES.
FROM BEING CAGED.
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED
[inaudible]
PEOPLE LOOK. TO THE WEST THEY
LOOK TO AMERICA.
SET THE TONE.
ON EVERY POLICY.
YOU CAN IMAGINE.
THINK ABOUT THE MESSAGE THAT IT
SENDS RIGHT NOW ABOUT WHAT THIS
COUNTRY THINKS ABOUT CHILDREN.
GIVEN THE TREATMENT.
THEIR REFUGEE TREAT CHILDREN ARE
BEING PROVIDED YOU DON'T NEED TO
BE A PSYCHOLOGIST. TO UNDERSTAND
THE NEGATIVE IMPACT.
THAT IS BEING HAD.
ON CHILDREN WERE CRYING.
MOMMY POPPY FOR THEIR PARENTS.
IN THE FACE.
BOB GUARDS WHO WILL SAY THINGS
LIKE DON'T THEY SOUND LIKE AN
ORCHESTRA [inaudible]
RIDICULING THEM.
IN THE FACE OF A NATIONAL LEADER
AN INTERNATIONAL LEADER.
WHO SAYS THAT AMERICA WON'T BE A
REFUGEE HOLDING CENTER WHERE OUR
HUMANITARIAN VALUES? TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND I'LL TELL YOU THIS
I WAS NOT A REFUGEE.
BUT I SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE
GROWING UP WITHOUT MY PARENTS.
FROM THE TIME I WAS SIX YEARS
OLD.
AND SO WHEN I CELEBRATE FATHER'S
DAY I AM SO GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE
TO BE.
IN THE LIVES OF MY CHILDREN.
I GREW UP WITHOUT MY FATHER AND
MY MOTHER.
AND TODAY WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON
A RESOLUTION TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
IMPORTANCE OF FATHERS DAY I
INVITE EVERY MEMBER ON THIS
FLOOR. TO THINK ABOUT THIS
RESOLUTION AND WHAT IT REALLY
REPRESENTS FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF PARENTS.
WOULD YOU WANT YOUR CHILDREN
SEPARATED FROM YOU.
WOULD YOU WANT YOUR CHILDREN TO
BE INCARCERATED WOULD YOU WANT
YOUR CHILDREN TO BE [inaudible]
RIDICULE [inaudible]
I KNOW.
AND BELIEVE THAT FOR YOU THE
ANSWER WOULD BE NO RAISE YOUR
VOICE.
THE THE LEADERS OF THE WORLD SAY
THIS IS THE WRONG POLICY.
I STRONGLY URGE YOU I VOTE ON HR.
NINETY ONE THANK YOU MISTER US
KALRA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I THANK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD IN AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
RICHMOND.
SYNDICATED IS NOT JUST GOOD
ENOUGH FOR US TO SPEAK UP.
WE MUST ACT BECAUSE WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW REFLECTS ON
ALL OF US AS AMERICANS.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO THESE
CHILDREN'S CHILDREN THESE
FAMILIES --
IS A STATEMENT ABOUT WHO WE ARE.
AND WHAT WE DO RIGHT NOW SPEAKS
ABOUT WHO WE ARE NOT JUST AS
INDIVIDUALS NOT JUST HAS LEADERS
BUT AS A STATE.
AND A GREAT NATION.
THAT'S NOT ACTING SO GREAT RIGHT
NOW.
AND SO I IMPLORE EVERYONE THE DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN BOTH IN THIS
CHAMBER AND OUTSIDE THIS CHAMBER.
DO WHATEVER THEY CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE AT THE VERY LEAST
AS WE DEBATE.
NATIONALLY AT THE STATE LEVEL
IMMIGRATION POLICY IS WE DO
BROUGH COULD TO DEBATE PUBLIC
SAFETY IN ALL THESE ISSUES WE
DEBATE.
YOUR LONG IN THIS CHAMBER AND
MANY OTHERS ACROSS THIS NATION
THE RELEASE CAN AGREE ON THE
FACT THAT.
FAMILIES NOT BE SEPARATED BY
CHILDREN SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN
FROM THEIR MOTHERS.
AND FROM THEIR FATHERS AND
DESPITE THE RHETORIC THAT THIS
HAS BEEN A POLICY IN THE PAST WE
KNOW TIME AND AGAIN THIS IS
PROVEN TO BE UNTRUE.
BOTH UNDER THE BUSH AND OBAMA
PRESIDENCY THEY DID NOT.
WILLFULLY SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES.
AND SO BEACON REPEAT LIES AGAIN
AND AGAIN BUT WE KNOW THAT THEY
ARE LIES THE MATTER HOW MANY
TIMES THE REPEATED.
AND SO I WOULD JUST ASK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES ESPECIALLY THOSE.
OF THAT HAD THE ABILITY --
TO SPEAK.
ADD TO THIS PRESIDENT AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IN A WAY THAT
MAYBE SOME OF US DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BECAUSE OF
PARTISANSHIP OR WHATEVER IT
MIGHT BE. TO RAISE YOUR VOICE UP
SCIENCE IS UNACCEPTABLE AND AS
YOU WONDERED WHAT YOU WOULD HAVE
DONE.
WHEN CITIZENS OF JAPANESE
DESCENT WERE BEING PUT ON TRAINS?
AND SENT TO INTERNMENT CAMPS.
IF YOU WONDER WHAT YOU WOULD
HAVE DONE.
IF YOU WERE A* GERMANY.
WHEN JEWS WERE BEING SEGREGATED
INTO GHETTOS IF YOU'RE WONDERING
WHAT YOU WOULD DONE YOU'RE DOING
IT RIGHT NOW?
THERE WAS KALRA MISTER CHAVEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
OUR RESOLUTION.
AND I THOUGHT I WOULD ACTUALLY
READ OUR LITTLE BIT OF ACTION
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE VOTING ON
HERE PERMISSION TO READ
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
YOU'RE RESOLVED BY THE ASSEMBLY
SAY THE CALIFORNIA THAT THE
SIMPLY DOES.
ALL OF THE FOLLOWING.
REAFFIRMS THE BIPARTISAN.
COMMITMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO PROMOTE THE SAFETY HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF THE MILLIONS OF
REFUGEES.
AND DISPLACED PERSONS WHO FLEE
WAR.
PERSECUTION AND TORTURE.
IN SEARCH OF PEACE HOPE.
AND FREEDOM IN THE STATE.
THAT'S PRETTY IT'S A PRETTY GOOD
STATEMENT [inaudible]
SECOND.
CALLS UPON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO DO BOTH OF THE
FOLLOWING.
CONTINUE ITS INTERNATIONAL
LEADERSHIP ROLE.
INTERNATIONAL LEADERSHIP ROLE
RESPONSE TO THOSE HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED.
PLEASE THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
WHO IN YOUR SEXUAL VIOLENCE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING?
FORCED CONSCRIPTION GENOCIDE AND
EXPLOITATION.
AND SECOND FIND POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS TO EXISTING CONFLICTS
VENT NEW CONFLICT FROM BEGINNING.
YOU NO LAYS DOWN MIKE AS YOU DO
A LOT OF YOU KNOW.
I'VE BEEN AROUND THE WORLD A LOT
AND SEEN A LOT OF NOT SO AYE
SITUATIONS.
AND MANY PEOPLE DO.
WORRY ABOUT THEIR LIVES IN THE
YOU SEE PEOPLE BEING MOVED
AROUND THE THEIR BECAUSE OF
ECONOMIC OR WAR [inaudible]
THEIR SUFFERING.
I REMEMBER IN KOREA.
SEE IN A YEAR AND A A THIS OLDER
LADY HAD ABOUT TWENTY OR THIRTY
LITTLE REFUGEE KIDS ORPHANS.
AND IT WAS ABOUT. FIVE DEGREES
OUTSIDE.
IN THEY WOULD COME OUT OF THIS
LITTLE HOUSE.
EARLY IN THE MORNING IN THE IN
THE THE COLD IN THE FILE WAS
THERE.
AND THAT COME UP TO OUR UNITS
AND BEG FOR FOOD.
AND WOULD FEED HIM AND TAKE CARE
OF AMMA WE'RE ONLY THERE FOR A
COUPLE OF DAYS AND EVERY DAY
DIESEL KIDS WOULD COME UP JUST
LIKE OUT OF THE OUT OF THE FOG
LOOKING FOR FOOD IN THE MORNING.
AND THIS POOR LITTLE.
LADY TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF ALL
THESE REFUGEES LITTLE KIDS.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE GOT UP AND
MOVED FROM THERE.
OFTEN WONDER WHAT.
WILL WHO FEEDS THE KIDS NOW.
YOU KNOW WE'RE THERE TWO OR
THREE DAYS FEEDING THESE KIDS
BUT WHO TOOK CARE WHEN WE LEFT.
YOU DON'T I SEE THE PICTURES OF
THE KIDS CRYING TODAY THAT JUST
BREAKS MIA.
NOW THE OTHER PORTION NURSES
FIND THE POLITICAL SOLUTIONS.
YOU MUST BE UP FRONT WHAT BUT WE
ACTUALLY.
WHAT'S ACTUALLY YOU'RE THE LACK
OF LEADERS DOING TO DE SAY.
I ONE SIDE THEY'RE DOING SUB A
SOUTH.
SO ROUND AS TAKING CHILDREN AWAY.
FOR FOR THEIR PARENTS THE FORCED
THE ISSUE TO ACTUALLY COME TO
AGREEMENT.
ON WITH THEY WOULD SAY IS BUILD
A WALL FUND THE WALL THIS MAKE A
SO.
SUCH A CONFLICT OF PEOPLE GOING
TO COME AND SAY LESS SOLVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
YOU KNOW --
WE ALL READ HISTORY WE'VE ALSO
WE TALKED ABOUT ON THIS FLOOR
HERE WHERE.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ABUSED. FOR
WHATEVER THEY THOUGHT WAS A
REASON.
THE POLICY THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS SEPARATE THE
CHILDREN [inaudible]
ARE TO BRING ABOUT.
SO MEMBER GRAYSON FORM AND PUT
SOME WALL UP. TO MAY IS THE ENDS
DO NOT JUSTIFY THE MEANS.
WE SHOULD NOT BEING YOU
LEVERAGING. ONE OF THE CORE
COMPONENTS OF OUR SOCIETY AND
THAT'S THE FAMILY AND SEPARATE
THEM. FOR POLITICAL SOLUTION.
AS A REPUBLICAN.
A PROUD REPUBLICAN.
WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW IS
WRONG?
AND WE SHOULD VOTE FOR THIS
RESOLUTION WHICH HAS ENDED UP
AND SAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT IF YOU GUYS CAN
GET TOGETHER FOR GOD IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
IN YOU THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BLOW AVERAGE CHILDREN TO DO
THIS BY PUTTING AMEND LITTLE
CAMPS.
THAT I GOT NEWS FOR YOU GUYS ARE
MORE.
YOU HAVE MUCH BIGGER ISSUES TO
BE DEALT WITH.
BECAUSE YOU ARE JUST WRONG IN
EVERY SENSE OF THE WORD.
YOU ARE WRONG.
YOU SWEET OUR COUNTRY DOES NOT
TAKE CHILDREN AWAY FROM THE
PARENTS [inaudible]
THAT'S WRONG [inaudible]
THINGS CHAVEZ MISS MELENDEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION TODAY --
AND I JUST.
LISTENING TO THE COMMENTS IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE ARE DEBATING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THEN WHAT
HAS BEEN PRESENTED WE ARE THIS
IS A RESOLUTION ON REFUGEES IN
AMERICA'S COMMITMENT TO
ACCEPTING THEM.
AND HELPING THEM ONCE THEY'RE
HERE THIS IS NOT A RESOLUTION ON
THOSE TWO ARE IN AN IMMIGRATION
SITUATION OR THEY'RE SEEKING
ASYLUM --
HOWEVER [inaudible]
I JUST [inaudible] ONE ED.
ARE I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT I'M
I AM HAPPY TO HEAR SO MANY
PEOPLE STAND UP AND TALK ABOUT --
BET THEY ARE NOT SATISFIED WITH
SOME OF THE CONDITIONS --
THAT SOME OF THEIR CHILDREN HAVE
LIVED IN WEATHER THAT'S RIGHT
NOW OR WHETHER IT GOES BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN WHEN
THERE IS ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND
CENTRAL AMERICAN REFUGEES --
WHO WERE NOT GIVEN SUCH A WARM
WELCOME BUYER PRESIDENT AT THAT
TIME IN FACT I THINK WE HAD A?
DELEGATION OF LATINO LEGISLATORS
WHO WANTS TO ONE OF THESE
FACILITIES AND CAME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT THEY WERE
SATISFIED WITH THE CONDITIONS
THAT WERE THERE DESPITE THE FACT
THAT.
AS WE HAVE ALL SEEN THE PICTURES
HAD BEEN CIRCULATING OF CHILDREN.
WHO LOOKED LIKE THEY WERE IN
CAGES AND THOSE ARE PICTURES
FROM TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
THOSE ARE THE CONDITIONS?
THAT THOSE CHILDREN ARE LIVING
AND SO I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
DOESN'T WANT TO SEE THAT AMERICA
HAS TAKEN IN.
MORE REFUGEES THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY OUT THERE WE ARE A
GENEROUS NATION.
NOT ONLY DO WE ACCEPT THEM IN
BUT THERE'S FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
THEIR EDUCATION FOR THEM TO
LEARN JOB SKILLS FOR THEM TO
TAKE CARE THEIR FAMILIES AND
HEALTH CARE.
WE ARE A GENEROUS NATION WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE.
ON IT SO I JOIN WITH YOU IN
SUPPORTING.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MR MCCARTY YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY THIS
AFTERNOON FOR SPEAKING UP ON
THIS ISSUE.
NOT JUST HONORING THIS WEDNESDAY
THE TWENTIETH OF JUNE AS WORLD
REFUGEE DAY BUT REALIZING THAT
THE WORLD IS WATCHING US WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT HERE.
BECAUSE WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN YEARS
AGO WHEN KING EXAMPLE RAISED BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE ELSINORE.
THOSE CASES WERE UNACCOMPANIED
MINERS.
MANY OVER.
FOURTEEN AS WE SAW THIS WEEKEND.
A LITTLE GIRL TWO YEARS OLD FROM
HONDURAS HER AND HER MOTHER.
WERE SEEKING TO BE REFUGEES
GOING THE BORDER SEEKING ASYLUM.
AS THE PROCESS HAS BEEN WORKING
FOR DECADES.
AND THAT'S NOT BE AMERICA THAT
WE KNOW AND LOVE THAT'S WHY
BIPARTISAN LEADERS FROM ACROSS
OUR NATION ARE SPEAKING UP
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SPEAKING UP
TODAY.
THE TODAY WE'RE SAYING YES.
UNANIMOUSLY ON HR NINETY ONE
WERE SAYING YES WE WANT AND A
MORAL.
AND JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT TO
MILITARY THAT ARE BORDER AS WE
DEAL WITH OUR IMMIGRATION AND
REFUGEE PROCESS.
AND DOWN AND I DO HOPE THAT AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM OCEANSIDE.
NOTED THAT OTHERS ARE WATCHING
AND THIS CAN LEAD US TO BRING
RESOLUTION TO WHAT WE SEE HERE
HAS A VERY SAD UNFORTUNATE
CHAPTER IN OUR UNITED STATES
HISTORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY AND MR
MCCARTY YOU WOULD LIKE THE FIRST
ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION I BELIEVE MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK LOOKED IN THE ROLL-ON
WALKERS.
ON HR NINETY ONE CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THERE ARE LOCAL CLOSER ROLE
SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED AND MR
MCCARTY I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
GUESTS WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY ON THIS RESOLUTION.
YES MISTER SPEAKER YOU KNOW
WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE ON THE
FRONT LINES.
THERE ARE PEOPLE [inaudible]
IT'S AN WE HAVE A GAS
INTRODUCTION ON THE RESOLUTION
THEY'LL BE ORDER IN THE CHAMBER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER SPEAKER AS WE NOTED THERE
ARE PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE AND WITH
US TODAY.
ARE FIVE OF THE RESETTLEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS LOCATED HERE IN
THE GREEK COMMUNITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN MY DISTRICT
WORKING A LOT IN THE DESERT O
MY COLLEAGUE FROM RANCHO CORDOVA.
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE LEADERS
FROM OPENING DOORS INCORPORATED.
THE INTERNATIONAL RESCUE
COMMITTEE.
CANYON COMMITTEE WHILE FAMILY
CAN MEAN DEVELOPMENT THE
SACRAMENT OF FOOD BANK AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND WILL RELATE
OF SACRAMENTO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK IN OUR COMMUNITY RESETTLING
REFUGEES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
RECESS THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL
OF THE SPEAKER.
WE ARE IN RECESS
MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
SO WE MAY PROCEED WITH THE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE HOUSE
.
MEMBERS SESSION AS RESUME PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
MEMBERS ON THE THIRD READING
FILE.
FILE ITEMS [inaudible] EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY SEVEN
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY FOUR THAT IS A C. OUR TO
FORTY NINE BY MISTER GALLAGHER
IN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER RELATIVE TO FATHER'S
DAY [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION
MISTER GALLAGHER MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT ACR TO FORTY NINE A
RESOLUTION WHICH RECOGNIZES.
THE POSITIVE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
FATHERS AND FATHER FIGURES.
WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN?
AS MANY OF US CELEBRATED
YESTERDAY FATHER'S DAY --
AND SOME OF EVEN TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW THAT GATHERING OF OF
FAMILIES.
THEY IT'S IMPORTANT BUT I
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US
AS A BODY. TO ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF FATHERS AND
FATHERHOOD.
FATHERHOOD IS A BLESSING.
BEING A PARENT.
I THINK REFINES IT MATURES YOU.
I KNOW I FOR ONE AND NOT THE
SAME MAN I WAS BEFORE MY KIDS
[inaudible]
WERE BORN.
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE MAN
THAT THEY ARE HELPING ME BECOME.
I THINK ABOUT MY OWN FATHER IN
THE THINGS THAT.
THAT HE TAUGHT ME AND THERE ARE
MANY THINGS THAT HE TAUGHT ME
BUT MAYBE THE MOST IMPORTANT WAS.
HOW TO BE TRULY LOVING AND
RESPECTFUL? TO MY WIFE.
AND HOW TO BE INTENTIONAL
[inaudible]
AND ENGAGE.
WITH MY KIDS.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT CHILDREN
WITH INVOLVED FATHERS ARE ARE
BETTER EQUIPPED. FOR THE
INEVITABLE CHALLENGES OF LIFE
THEY PERFORM BETTER AT SCHOOL.
ARE LESS LIKELY TO GROW UP IN
POVERTY OR FACE FOOD INSECURITY.
AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
CHILDHOOD DEPRESSION.
HOWEVER TOO MANY.
THE OF OUR CHILDREN GROW UP
WITHOUT FATHERS YOU KNOW FAR TOO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
AND I LOOK BACK I THINK OF TO
EFFORTS BOTH THE WAR ON POVERTY
AND THE WAR ON DRUGS.
HAD THE EFFECT OF REMOVING MANY
FATHERS.
FROM THE HOME.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR INNER CITIES
AND OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE SEEN IN MY OWN DISTRICT.
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE MANY JET
THERE WHERE SEVERAL GENERATIONS
NOW GROWN UP.
EITHER WITHOUT FATHERS WITHOUT
ANY POSITIVE MALE ROLE MODELS IN
THE COMMUNITY.
THANK GOD BLESS A SINGLE MOTHERS.
AND THE GRANDPARENTS IN THE
EXTENDED FAMILY WHO ARE DOING
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE KIDS HAVE A
FIGHTING CHANCE BUT TOO OFTEN IT
IS A VICIOUS CYCLE.
AND SO TODAY I WHEN WE TALK.
THEN THIS LEGISLATURE'S FACING
SO MANY ISSUES AND CALIFORNIA
ONLY TALK ABOUT ISSUES OF
POVERTY.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT LACK OF
UPWARD MOBILITY?
WE TALK ABOUT HOME STABILITY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
ESPECIALLY IN OUR YOUTH.
WILL BE SEEN IN SOME OF THESE
MASS SHOOTINGS.
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH NO DIRECTION
AND THAT WOULD GO AND ACTUALLY
DO THAT.
AND MANY OF THOSE CASES.
NO FATHERS NO FATHER FIGURES.
THERE TO STEP IN.
SO WE KNOW THAT FATHERS HAVE A
VERY CRITICAL ROLE TO PLAY.
IN ALL THESE ISSUES AND SO WAS
TODAY AS WE ARE AS WE
COMMEMORATE AS WE CELEBRATED
YESTERDAY FATHER'S DAY.
LET'S COMMIT OURSELVES.
NOW LET ME JUST ECHO.
LET ME JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE PREVIOUS
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
ANY POLICY [inaudible]
ANY POLICY THEY WOULD
ARBITRARILY RIP.
FROM THERE PICKED THEIR CHILDREN
FROM THEIR PARENTS HANDS.
IS WRONG IT SHOULD CEASE
IMMEDIATELY.
SO TODAY ON AS WE COMMEMORATE AS
WE COMMIT OURSELVES.
TELL BEEN CONNECT IN EMPOWER
FATHERS.
LET'S CONTINUE THAT WORK ARE
COMMUNITIES DESPERATELY NEEDED.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
MISTER HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY YOU SPEAKER AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBER FROM NICHOLAS
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE --
FOR I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
IN SUPPORT OF ACR TO FORTY NINE
RECOGNIZING FATHERS DAY.
THEY CAN'T BE SAID ENOUGH THAT
FATHERS PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES WE KNOW
HOW VITAL THEIR INVOLVEMENT IS
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE.
WHEN A CHILD HAS NO FATHER
FIGURE?
AND THE AFGHAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY OVER 40% OF FATHERS
DON'T LIVE WITH THEIR CHILDREN
AND FOR CHILDREN UNDER FIVE THIS
CAN HAVE A DETRIMENTAL EFFECT.
ON THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
FROM MASS INCARCERATION THE
DOMESTIC IT DISRUPTION FATHERS
HAVE BEEN STRIPPED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN SIMILAR TO WHAT'S BEEN
DONE AT THE BORDERS DUE TO ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICIES.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME FATHERS WERE
NOT ABLE TO BE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN THIS FATHER'S DAY.
WHICH MAKES ME ME EVEN MORE
PRESIDIO THE TIME THAT I'VE HAD
WITH MY FAMILY.
THE FATHER OF FIVE I TAKE PRIDE
IN BEING INVOLVED WITH MY
CHILDREN.
AND NEVER TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
TIME WE SPEND TOGETHER.
I PRISSY I'M APPRECIATIVE OF MY
FATHER.
AND FATHER LIKE FIGURES THAT
HAVE RAISED THEIR KIDS TO BE THE
CHANGE THAT AMERICA NEEDS.
BEING INVOLVED IS ALL WE CAN ASK
FOR AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
GREAT FATHERS OUT THERE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
TAKING HIS HOLDEN DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU OF MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM NICHOLAS ALSO FOR ASKING ME
TO SHARE WITH.
YOU SOME THOUGHTS ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DAY.
A IN OUR CELEBRATION OF FATHER'S
DAY.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR TWO
FORTY NINE RECOGNIZING ALL OF
THE GREAT FATHER'S IN THIS
NATION.
AND WHAT THEY HAVE MEANT.
PARTICULARLY I RISE BECAUSE SO
OFTEN THE INFORMATION AND THAT
COMES OUT CONCERNING AFRICAN
AMERICAN FATHERS IS NOT ALWAYS
COMPLIMENTARY.
WE OFTEN HEAR BABY DADDY
COMMENTS AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT GIVE US THAT IMAGE.
OF OF AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO A
FATHER'S.
AND YET WHEN I THINK ABOUT MY
FATHER.
AT NOT JUST THE MAN WHO HAVE WAS
A SHARECROPPER COMING TO
CALIFORNIA FOR HOPE AND
ASPIRATIONS VOICE CHILDREN.
BUT A MAN WHO TRULY LOVED HIS
FAMILY.
ALL OF HIS HEART.
IN ALL OF HIS MIGHT.
AND ALL OF HIS DREAMS AND ALL OF
HIS DISAPPOINTMENTS PUT ASIDE.
FOR THE LOVE AND CARE OF HIS
CHILDREN.
YOU SEE BARON AWFUL LOT OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN.
WE'RE NOT FAMOUS MEN.
WOULD NOT NOTABLE MEN WOULD NOT
LEADERS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES WHO
NOT PASTORS OF CHURCHES.
WHO REALLY MAKE ENORMOUS
SACRIFICES FOR THEIR CHILDREN?
AND IT'S KIND OF AMAZING BECAUSE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
AND HOW THIS COUNTRY HAS TREATED
AFRICAN AMERICAN FAMILIES
HISTORICALLY FOR OVER TWO
HUNDRED YEARS.
WHAT WE SEPARATED THE MEN FROM
THEIR CHILDREN AND FROM THEIR
WIVES AND WE HAD BREEDING FARMS
WE LITERALLY BREED OF THESE MEN
AND USE THEM ONLY TO CREATE MORE
SLAVES?
AND YET AT THE END OF SLAVERY WE
FIND THAT THE ONE THING THEY
SOUGHT MOST OFTEN WAS TO FIND
THEIR FAMILIES.
AND IF THEY DIDN'T WAS TO
ESTABLISH A FAMILY.
AND TO BELIEVE IN THAT FAMILY
AND TO GIVE ALL THEY COULD EVEN
IN THE FACE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY MET IN AMERICA. TO BE
FATHERS.
MY DAD WAS A GREAT MAN.
NOT REALLY EDUCATED DIDN'T HAVE
A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT HE LOVED HIS EIGHT CHILDREN.
WITH ALL OF HIS HEART.
HE HAD ONE SUIT THAT HE WORE
BECAUSE HE WAS A MASON.
AND HE HAD ONE GOOD BLACK SUIT
AND A PAIR OF STACY ADAMS SHOES
THAT LASTED FOR TWENTY YEARS
THAT HE WORE TO MAJOR EVENTS.
NOT BECAUSE UPON HIS DEATH HE
HAD LOTS OF SUITS BECAUSE EIGHT
CHILDREN MADE SURE THAT HE THEY
THAT WE BOUGHT HIM EVERYTHING WE
THOUGHT HE WON IT.
BUT HE NEVER LET US EVER BE
DISAPPOINTED IN LIFE.
WE ALWAYS KNEW WHERE WE WERE
GOING TO SLEEP.
WE'RE GOING TO EAT.
WE'RE ALWAYS COMFORTABLE.
AND WE KNEW THAT IF WE WERE TO
FALL HE WOULD PICK US UP.
WE KNEW THAT IF THERE WERE
DISAPPOINTMENTS HE COULD MAKE A
SMILE AND GIVE US WHAT WE NEEDED.
TOLD ME HOW IMPORTANT EDUCATION
WAS EVERY DAY OF MY LIFE.
AND THAT HE WOULD QUOTE DRINK
MUDDY WATER AND SLEEP IN A
HOLLOW LOG IN WANTED TO SEND ME
TO SCHOOL.
AND HE MEANT EVERY WORD OF THAT.
AND IS A POWERFUL FORCE THOUGH
GIRL TO FIGHT. TO LIVE FOR THE
NEXT DAY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE STRONG AND PRINT THE
RESILIENT.
MY DAD WOULD PICK ME UP AT UCLA.
I DID NOTICE THINGS.
LIKE THE GIRLS HEAD ON KNEE
SOCKS I DIDN'T EVEN LIKE KNEE
SOCKS.
BUT MY DAD SOLVE THEM AND HE
TOOK US TO THE UCLA S. C. GAME
AT THE COLISEUM ANYONE HOME SAID
TO MY MOTHER YOU GOTTA GO BY HER
SYDNEY SOCKS BECAUSE THE COLLEGE
GIRLS WHEN THE SOCKS.
AND OF COURSE I GOT SOME DIDN'T
LIKE HIM BUT ALWAYS WARM WHEN I
SAW HIM.
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT I NEEDED ME SIGH.
YOU CAN AFFORD TO BUY ME A CAR.
BUT I WORKED AND BOUGHT A CAR
BUT HE MADE SURE THAT CAR WAS
CHECKED OUT EVERY WEEKEND TO
MAKE SURE THE OIL WAS GOOD THE
TIRES ROACH STRAIGHT AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS TO MAKE SURE
THAT I HE PARTICIPATED.
IN MY EDUCATION.
AND EVERYTHING THAT WAS THERE HE
DID IT. ONE STORY I REMEMBER
HE'D NEVER SAW ME REALLY STUDY
HARD BECAUSE I LIVED IN THE DORM
BUT WHEN I CAME HOME ONE SUMMER.
I WAS STUDYING OVER AND OVER FOR
A GREEK MOMENT OR TOWARDS
PRESENTATION.
IT WAS ONLY TEST THAT WAS NO
OTHER UP.
ANYTHING JUST ONE TEST.
AND I HAD TO START STUDYING IN
THE MORNING AND I STUDY NAY
AFTERNOON ABOUT OUT THERE IN THE
HIT WE GOT HOME I WAS STILL
STUDYING.
A FRIDAY NIGHT INVESTED IT ALL
NIGHT LONG.
MY DADDY GOT UP AND WALKED BACK
AND FORTH TO THE BATHROOM I
THOUGHT SOMETHING WAS WRONG WITH
HIM AND HE PEOPLE AND SAY HAVING
TO FINISH YET.
AND I SAY NO LESS DEVELOPMENT
MORE.
AND HE WAS SO CONCERNED ALL
NIGHT LONG.
FIND OUT TO SLEEP ABOUT.
FOUR THIRTY FIVE ONLY TO WAKE UP
AND SEE A CLOCK. TO THE SMELL OF
BACON AND EGGS IN THE KITCHEN.
BEING COOKED BY MY FATHER WHO
HAD WORKED FIFTY HOURS THAT WEEK
TEN HOURS A DAY EVERY DAY.
AND YET HE GOT UP IN THE MORNING
ON SATURDAY.
COOKED MY BREAKFAST.
HE SAID TO ME JUST DRIVE TO DO
WELL.
SO MY GREAT OF AN A CAME IN THE
NEXT WEEK UP PUT IT ON HIS MAIL.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT HE HAD
EARNED.
I SAY THIS NOT SAY THIS OFTEN TO
FATHERS ALL ACROSS THE NATION
YOU MAY NOT HAVE ALL OF THESE
THINGS A HOLLYWOOD IN THE MOVIES
TELL PEOPLE THAT THEY NEED.
WHAT'S YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MOTIVATE YOUR CHILDREN.
SHOW THEM THAT YOU LOVE THEM.
I GIVE THEM THE STRENGTH TO
PERSEVERE INS TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND I CELEBRATE ALL OF THOSE
ORDINARY FATHERS EVERYDAY.
SIMPLY AND QUIETLY LOVE THEIR
CHILDREN TO GREATNESS.
I RESPECT MY COLLEAGUE AND I
ASKED ALL OF US TO THINK ABOUT
WHO WE ARE.
THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE
SOME REALLY GREAT MAN WAS
STRUGGLING EVERY DAY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
AND TO SET THEIR KIDS ON THE
RIGHT PATH. TO VOTE YES FOR ACR
[inaudible] FORTY NINE THEY
CONDUCT WEBER.
MR LEVINE YOU MAY FOLLOW THAT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THINKING MEMBERS THIS SIDE.
THIS CONVERSATION GOT DEEP AT
THE GET GO.
DID I I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM YUBA CITY.
PRINCE USING THE RESOLUTION IT
SIDE.
SOME OF ALL OF US CAN AGREE ON
YOU KNOW.
PARTISANSHIP AND POLITICS ASIDE --
ABOUT PARENTHOOD --
AND CERTAINLY US THOSE OF US WHO
ARE FATHERS.
MOST IMPORTANT JOB WE'VE GOT.
ABSOLUTE MOST IMPORTANT JOB
WE'VE GOT.
AND AND SOME THAT I'VE NOTICED.
NOW THAT A A NUMBER OF US.
ARE SOME OF THE OLD GUYS HERE.
MORE OF US ARE DADS --
AND HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN --
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS.
THEN WE HAD IN THE PAST AND IT'S
SO.
IT'S BEEN A NICE THING ALSO SOME
NICE TO TALK ABOUT.
WITH US COLLEAGUES ABOUT HOW WE
GET THAT TIME WITH OUR KIDS
[inaudible]
HOW WE?
GET ARE TENSION BACK TO THEM OR
KEEP OUR ATTENTION ON THEM EVEN
ARE NOT ABLE TO BE THERE HOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS FATHER'S
IS FAR MORE IMPORTANT.
IT OUR JOB AS LEGISLATORS AS
IMPORTANT AS IT IS.
AND DIED AND SOMETHING THAT I
KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM YUBA
CITY.
AGREES WITH ME ON THIS MOST
IMPORTANT JOB IS THE BEST JOB.
WILL EVER HAVE AT SOME THAT
WE'VE GOT TO DO IS FATHER'S WITH
PURPOSE [inaudible]
AND MEANING.
AND THE IN GIVE OUR CHILDREN OUR
FULL ATTENTION.
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFETIMES.
HIS RECENT RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
WILL HAVE THROUGHOUT OUR
LIFETIMES.
I THINK MANY OF US HAD NOT SEEN
OUR STOMACH YESTERDAY.
AS WE WERE CELEBRATING FATHER'S
DAY.
AND CELEBRATING FAMILY.
AND I GOTTA TELL YEAH I WAS
REALLY PROUD TO HAVE VOTED FOR A
MOM TO BE PRESIDENT.
ON FATHER'S DAY.
URGE EVERYONE I VOTER NAY SIR.
TO FORTY NINE THANK YOU MICHELLE
THEY MISS YOUR MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ARE GONNA
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY --
ONE ASSURE THIS AWESOME TIME MY
SONS GOT ME FOR FATHER'S DAY --
BUT TO READ ONE MY FAVORITE.
POEMS IN REGARDS --
TO BEING A DADDY WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
WALK A LITTLE SLOWER DADDY.
SO THE LITTLE CHILD SO SMALL.
I'M FOLLOWING IN YOUR FOOTSTEPS
AND I DON'T WANT TO FALL.
SOMETIMES YOUR STEPS ARE VERY
FAST.
SOMETIMES A VERY HARD TO SEE.
SO WALK A LITTLE SLOWER DADDY.
FOR YOU ARE LEADING ME.
SOMEDAY WHEN I'M ALL GROWN UP.
YOU'RE WHAT I WANT TO BE.
THEN I WILL HAVE A LITTLE CHILD.
WILL WANT TO FOLLOW ME.
AND I WOULD WANT TO LEAD JUST
RIGHT.
AND KNOW THAT I WAS TRUE.
SO WALK A LITTLE SLOWER DADDY.
FOR I MUST FOLLOW YOU.
MEMBERS I HAVE THIS POEM WITH MY
OLDEST SON'S FOOTPRINTS OF MY
OFFICE JUST KEEP A SIMPLE
REMINDER.
SOLICIT THE EXAMPLE JUST WALK A
LITTLE SLOWER AND GET IT RIGHT
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
HEY RICH MATHIS.
SEEING KNOW ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE TWINS CAUCUS
MISTER GALLAGHER MAKE CLOTHES.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
HONORARY MEMBER --
JUST THIS YEAR OF THE TWINS
CAUCUS -- SO --
THANK YOU TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES
TO HELP SHARE AND THEIR THOUGHTS
ON THIS RESOLUTION --
MEN AND I THINK YOU KNOW.
THE GENTLEWOMAN FROM SAN DIEGO
ALWAYS SAYS IT SO WELL --
YEAH AND REALLY GIVES US THE
PICTURE.
WHAT THAT MEANS IN I AND I THINK
THE WORD THAT I PICKED UP SO
VERY WELL THERE IS IS TO BE IN
THE ORDINARY?
FATHER YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
EXTRAORDINARY WE ALL MAKE
MISTAKES AND THOSE OF US WHO ARE
FATHERS KNOW THAT VERY WELL --
BUT IT'S THE ORDINARY.
AND EVERYDAY AND I THINK WHAT
YOU LEARN MOST AS BEING A THAT I
BEING A FATHER MEANS ABOUT.
SACRIFICE IT MEANS ABOUT NOT
BEING SELFISH.
AND ABOUT BEING THERE FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR FAMILY --
AND YEAH AS I SAID I THINK VERY
FONDLY ON WHAT YOU KNOW.
AND I THINK ALL OF US.
I CAN TAKE SOMETHING FROM THIS
AND SAY LOOK WE KNOW WE NEED. TO
TO MAKE THAT SACRIFICE WE NEED
TO TAKE THAT TIME WE NEED TO
SLOW DOWN --
AS A GENTLEMAN.
FROM BY SAY A SAID --
AND REALLY FOCUS IN AND THINK
ABOUT HOW OUR POLICIES --
CAN AFFECT WE KNOW THE POLICIES
THAT.
HAVE BEEN ENACTED --
HAVE REALLY DECIMATED THE AMOUNT
OF FATHERS THAT WE HAVE.
IN THIS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
POLICIES THAT CAN TEAR FAMILIES
APART.
RATHER BRING THEM TOGETHER SO
HOW DO WE NOT ONLY KEEP THAT
FROM HAPPENING BUT HOW DO WE
PASS POLICIES THAT ACTUALLY.
HELP INCENTIVIZE AND PROMOTE
THAT HAPPENING AND I THINK IF WE
CAN DO THAT --
WE WILL SEASON SOME MAJOR
BREAKTHROUGHS ON SO MANY VERY
VARIOUS ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING
TODAY.
OF FATHERS ARE PART OF THAT
SOLUTION SO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING WITH ME TODAY AND ASK
YOUR ABOUT.
THINGS GALLAGHER WAS GALLAGHER
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AUTHORS ON THE
FIRST ROLE [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS THIS IS COAUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ON A C. R..
TO FORTY NINE CO AUTHORS ADDING
ON THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THERE SEVENTY FOUR
SUPERBLY SEVENTY FIVE COAUTHORS
ADDED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE ONE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE A SEE ARE.
TO FIFTY ONE CORKERY ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO FIFTY
ONE LATELY NUMBER GLORIA
RELATIVE TO PHILIPPINE
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
MISTER GLORIA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AS A MEMBER OF THE
API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I'M PROUD
TO RISE THIS AFTERNOON TO
PRESENT ACR.
TO FIFTY ONE WHICH RECOGNIZES
MONDAY JUNE TWELFTH AS THE
HUNDRED TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
PHILIPPINE INDEPENDENCE DAY.
A PHILIPPINE INDEPENDENCE DAY
MARKS THE DAY IN HISTORY THE
FILIPINO SUCCESSFULLY GAINED
INDEPENDENCE FOLLOWING THREE
HUNDRED YEARS OF SPANISH
COLONIAL RULE.
AND COLLEAGUES PHILIPPINE
INDEPENDENCE DAY AT ITS CORE IS
ABOUT THE FIGHT FOR FREEDOM
LIBERTY SELF DETERMINATION AND
INDEPENDENCE PUBLISHED ON
FAMILIAR TO A LOT OF US IN THIS
ROOM.
AND ALTHOUGH THAT FIGHT FOR JOE
INTO THAT FIGHT FOR JUSTICE A
SPIRIT OF RESILIENCE AND
COMPASSION HAS BEEN INGRAINED IN
THE FILIPINO CULTURE.
SPIRIT THAT WAS EMBODIED A BY
THE FILIPINO PROTESTERS WHO
HANDED OUT FLOWERS TO THE
SOLDIERS DURING THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX POWER.
PEOPLE POWER REVOLUTION FIGHTING
FORCE WITH COMPASSION.
AND THIS SPIRIT THAT RESONATED
WITH THE LATE ANTHONY BOURDAIN
WHEN HE VISIT THE PHILIPPINES
AND WHEN HE SAID THAT QUOTE
FILIPINOS ARE. FOR REASONS I
HAVE YET TO FIGURE OUT PROBABLY
THE MOST GIVING OF ALL THE
PEOPLE ON THE PLANET.
TODAY WE COMMEMORATE NOT ONLY
THE FIGHT FOR JUSTICE.
SPIRITED RESILIENCE IN OF
COMPASSION IN THE FILIPINO
COMMUNITY THAT HAS REVERBERATED
THROUGHOUT THEIR EFFORTS TO
PURSUE JUSTICE AND INDEPENDENCE.
THAT FIGHT FOR JUSTICE LIVES ON
TODAY WITH THE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION FILIPINO AMERICANS WHO
LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY. ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION OF WHICH LIVE RIGHT
HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
IT'S LIVES ON IN THE PURSUIT OF
THEIR OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
SURVIVE AND THRIVE IN A STATE
THAT BELIEVES IN THEM.
AND THEN A STATE THAT HAS GIVEN
THEM OPPORTUNITIES THAT I KNOW
CERTAINLY FROM MY FAMILY ARE SO
GREATLY APPRECIATED.
AC FIFTY ACR FIVE TO FIFTY ONE
IS A TESTAMENT TO THE RESILIENCE
AND COMPASSIONATE FILIPINOS.
I LOOK FOR TO COMMEMORATING THE
SACRIFICES MADE BY THE FILIPINO
COMMUNITY FOR ITS SOVEREIGNTY.
AS WE WORK IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THIS
GREAT STATE IN FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF CALIFORNIA ANCHORS
ALL OF US TO REMAIN COMMITTED TO
THAT'S PURSUIT OF JUSTICE IN
THAT SPIRIT OF RESILIENCE AND
COMPASSION.
SHOWN BY FILIPINO AMERICANS.
THANK YOU ALL SO VERY MUCH
SALAMAT PO AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND ASK
THAT FOR THE CLERK TO OPEN ITS
FIRST RULE FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION.
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CORPORAL.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON ACR.
TWO FIFTY ONE ARE CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER OTHER SEVENTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ADMITTED WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO ME WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY SIX MEMBERS ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING [inaudible]
FILE.
FILE ITEMS.
TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH
[inaudible]
FORTY TWO PASTOR RETAIN.
WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY THREE SAYS S. B.
[inaudible]
EIGHT FOUR SEVEN COOPERATE.
SAMPLE EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY THE
COMMITTEE A BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE COURTS
MAKING OPERATION THERE FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MR TENURE MEHLMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN IS OUR COURTS TRAILER BILL.
THE THOUGHTLESSNESS TO
JUDGESHIPS IN RIVERSIDE SUPERIOR
COURT IN APPELLATE JUSTICE IN
THE FOURTH APPELLATE DISTRICT.
A DOZEN MN SO I PRAYED TO
DIRECT UNPAID RESIDUAL CLASS
ACTION SETTLEMENTS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WERE FOUNDATION
SUPPORT PROJECTS THAT WILL
BENEFIT THE CLASS.
SIMILARLY SITUATED PEOPLE.
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR ONLINE ADJUDICATION
OF TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
BIG TING MISTER OBERNOLTE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
BILL ALLOCATES AN ADDITIONAL TWO
JUDGES TO THE RIVERSIDE SUPERIOR
COURT.
THESE JUDGES ARE BADLY NEEDED
HOWEVER THIS IS JUST A DROP IN
THE BUCKET ACCORDING TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THE JUDICIAL NEED IS FOR
AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE MORE JUDGES IN CALIFORNIA
COURTS AND THAT'S JUST TO MEET
THE CURRENT NEED THAT WE HAVE.
SO IT'S GREAT THAT WE'RE
ALLOCATING AN ADDITIONAL TWO BUT
I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT IN FUTURE
YEARS WE CAN MAKE PUTS A
MEANINGFUL RESOURCES TOWARD
MEETING THIS UNMET NEED.
I ALSO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
WAY THAT THESE JUDGES ARE BEING
AWARDED.
THIS A PRACTICE OF AWARDING THEM
TWO ONE CERTAIN CORD VIOLATES
LONGSTANDING LEGISLATIVE
PRACTICE OF ALLOWING THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO ALLOCATE
JUDGESHIPS ACCORDING TO THEIR
ASSESSMENT OF JUDICIAL NEED.
OF THIS TURNS IT INTO A
POLITICAL ISSUE WHICH I THINK SO
I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I'M
A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED.
ABOUT THE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
AND I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER IN THE FUTURE.
THING WHICH OBERNOLTE SEEN NO.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM MISTER TEAM A CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
WITH THAT CORP LIBERAL.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DECIDED VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL-ON I SIXTY NINE NEWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM OR FORTY FOUR
S. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE COVERAGE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY FIVE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
TAXATION MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
MISTER CHENEY MAKE AN OPEN.
I THINK YOU WOULD SPEAKER S. B.
A FIVE FIVE AS OUR TRAILER BILL
RELATING TO TAX CREDITS.
THIS EXPANDS THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT TO WORKING
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AGED
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR FOUR
AGED OVER SIXTY FIVE ARE VERY.
BY REVISING THE EIGHT RENTAL CAR
WITH THE DEFINITION OF AN
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUAL.
ALSO EXPANDS A QUALIFYING INCOME
RAGE FOR THE EITC SO THAT
EMPLOYEES WITH ONE OR MORE
DEPENDENTS WORKING UP TO FULL
TIME AT TWENTY NINETEEN MIN WAGE
OF TWELVE DOLLARS PER HOUR WILL
QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT.
IT ALSO EXTENDS UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THE CAL COMPETES A
ALLOWANCE FOR HIRING QUALIFIED
FULL TIME EMPLOYEES WITHIN
SPECIFIC CENSUS TRACK OR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AREA.
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
THEY WISH TING SEE KNOW
DISCLOSURE DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO'S OUT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE A VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS.
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
FORTY SIX S. B.. EIGHT SIXTY SIX
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY SIX BUT
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND EXPLAIN TO EMPLOYMENT
MAKE IN PREPARATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
MR JIANG.
THINKING WAS SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT
SIX SIX ANOTHER GENERAL
GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL THIS
INCLUDES LANGUAGE TO IMPROVE OUR
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM.
MAKES CHANGES TO EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION.
ACQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
COUNT CENSUS TO SUBMIT REPORTS
REGARDING.
THE CENSUS IN REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD TO ADMINISTER A PRISON TO
IMPLEMENT PROGRAM IN AWARDS
GRANTS.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THEY MISSED TING MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL ENACTS A WIDE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT POLICY CHANGES.
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR AN EMPLOYEE
TO LEAVE OUR UNION.
BUT THIS BILL APPARENTLY
PRESUPPOSES A DECISION BY THE
SUPREME COURT THAT WOULD MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR UNION TO
COLLECT AGENCY FREEZE FROM
EMPLOYEES THAT DON'T WISH TO PAY
THEM SO.
FIRST OF ALL I THINK IT'S VERY
INAPPROPRIATE TO PRESUPPOSE A
JUDGMENT THAT HAS NOT YET
OCCURRED.
ALTHOUGH I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE RIGHT OF EMPLOYEE TO FREELY
ASSOCIATE WITH THE UNION AND TO
ASK THAT UNION TO REPRESENT THEM
WITH THEIR EMPLOYER.
I AM ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE.
OF EMPLOYEES RIGHT TO LEAVE THE
UNION IF THEY DECIDE THAT UNION
NO LONGER REPRESENTS THEIR BEST
INTEREST THIS BILL ACTS AGAINST
THAT RIGHT AND I URGE A NO VOTE.
THING WHICH OBERNOLTE MISTER
FONG.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS AT
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL --
THERE IS IT A SPECIFIC PROVISION
IN THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT
DIRECTLY INTERFERES WITH THE
OPERATIONS AND THE FISCAL HEALTH
OF THE CURRENT HEALTH AUTHORITY
AND KERN MEDICAL --
IT IS THE ONLY PUBLIC HEALTH
HOSPITAL AND KERN COUNTY IS THE
ONLY TRAUMA CENTER IN KERN
COUNTY IT DIRECTLY AFFECTS AND
HARMS THE PUBLIC IN FISCAL
HEALTH OF THIS INSTITUTION. FOR
THAT REASON I ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FONG.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WHO STARTED VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT I
SHOULD FOR KNOWS TWENTY FIVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE.
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
AS WELL AS IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
OF FILE ITEM. FORTY FOUR THAT'S
S. B. EIGHT FIFTY FIVE ALSO
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
WITHOUT MEMBERS WORK FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY ONE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND EXPLAINED
TAXATION MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN ONE EXPANDS OUR FILM
TAX CREDIT FOR ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS.
FROM TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THAT CREDITS WILL BE
VALUED AT UP TO THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISTER TANK MISTER
OBERNOLTE I THINK MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE I WAS A SUPPORTER OF
THIS TAX CREDIT WHEN WE EXTENDED
TWO YEARS AGO I ALSO SUPPORTED
THIS YEAR AND COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER I JUST WANT TO RAISE A
POINT AND THAT'S THAT IF WE ARE
IN AGREEMENT.
TODAY THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DIFFICULT BUSINESS CLIMATE MAKES
IT HARD FOR THE MOTION PICTURE
INDUSTRY TO COMPETE AGAINST THAT
INDUSTRY IN OTHER STATES.
WOULDN'T WE BE BETTER SERVED. TO
WORK TOGETHER TO IMPROVE OUR
BUSINESS CLIMATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE CAN'T
EXTEND TAX CREDITS TO EVERY
INDUSTRY THAT HAS DIFFICULTY
COMPETING.
NOW HAVING SAID THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST HAS FOUND
THAT THIS TAX CREDIT ACTUALLY
DOES WORK AND I DOES LEAD TO
INCREASED FILMING HERE IN ITS
FOR FULFILLING ITS --
IT'S OUR PURPOSE WHEN WE PASSED
ORIGINALLY SO AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE THE EXTENT IN
THE CALIFORNIA FILM TELEVISION
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT THIS
INDUSTRY CREATE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING.
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND BILLIONS
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR
CALIFORNIA'S REPUTATION AS THE
HOME OF FILM AND TV DRIVES MUCH
OF THE TOURISM OUR STATE.
SEES AS WELL THE CURRENT PROGRAM
SETS IN SUNSETS IN TWO YEARS ON
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY DUE
TO THE COMPLEXITY OF THE MOTION
PICTURE AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION --
INDUSTRY DECISION CHIU LOCATIONS
ARE MADE OFTEN HEAR MORE
ADVANCED MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTIONS AND NEED
THE CERTAINTY OF THE CALIFORNIA
FILM AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT.
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO CONSIDER
CALIFORNIA'S LOCATION AND THEIR
PRODUCTION PLANNING S. B. EIGHT
SEVEN ONE WILL EXTEND THE
EXISTING PROGRAM WITH SEVERAL
SEVERAL IMPROVEMENTS AS WELL FOR
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS.
THESE IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDE
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY OF THOSE WORKING IN
BELOW THE LINE POSITIONS THROUGH
INNOVATIVE CAREER TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
GATHERING INFORMATION ON THE
DIVERSITY OF THOSE HELMING THESE
PRODUCTIONS WHICH IS ABOVE THE
LINE.
CREATING A SAFE WORKPLACE BY
REQUIRING THE FILING UPS
HARASSMENT PREVENTION POLICIES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION.
INCLUDING IDENTIFYING WHO
RECEIVES SUCH COMPLAINTS AND
OTHER MORE TECHNICAL LOGISTICAL
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM TO
IMPROVE ITS ADMINISTRATION BUT I
WOULD SAY NOTABLY TO ALLOW --
ME A PROVISION IN THERE THAT
INCLUDES WORKING WITH OUR ISSUES
FOR OUR SCORES IN OUR MUSICIANS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE ALSO
BENEFITING FROM THE FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT.
WHICH WE WERE VERY HAPPY TO COME
TO AN AGREEMENT ON SO S. B.
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE WILL CONTINUE
TO RESTORE CALIFORNIA'S
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE FOR FILM
TV PRODUCTION.
AND TO BRING JOBS BACK TO
CALIFORNIA THUS ENSURING THAT
THIS VIBRANT FOUNDATIONAL
INDUSTRY REMAINS A PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MR BLOW.
YOUR RECOMMENDS CAN MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE SO ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY ONE
AND I WANT TO COMMEND.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM WHITTIER IN
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
HELP MOVE THIS --
OF THIS FORWARD CALIFORNIA HAS
IN FACT BEEN THE CAPITAL OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY FOR MOST
OF THE PAST CENTURY IN FACT
SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
IT'S PART OF OUR IDENTITY AND
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
ECONOMY UNFORTUNATELY THE
INDUSTRY HAS FOR YEARS BEEN
MOVING TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
AND I IT'S BEEN DOING THAT
INCIDENTAL --
TO THE AND THEY'RE BEING
INCENTIVES IN OTHER STATES AND
THAT'S WHY AS MANY OF YOU
REMEMBER WE PASSED.
AT THE BILL IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO PROTECT AND SUPPORT A
THRIVING ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT REAUTHORIZATION OF THE TAX
CREDIT IS PROVED TO BE AN
UNQUALIFIED SUCCESS PUMPING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BACK INTO
OUR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
THESE DOLLARS FLOWED DIRECTLY
INTO THE THOUSANDS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS EMPLOYED IN SOLID
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND THEY
SUSTAIN HUNDREDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THE FILM INDUSTRY.
AND FINALLY THEY SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
WELL WE CELEBRATE OUR SUCCESSES
WE CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT REST ON
OUR LAURELS FACED WITH
CONTINUING EFFORTS TO LURE FILM
AND CONTENT.
PRODUCTION ELSEWHERE IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON CALIFORNIA TO
TAKE STEPS TO ASSURE THAT WE
RETAIN OUR PLACE.
AS THE HOME OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY AND NEVER EVER
RELINQUISH THAT POSITION THAT'S
THE MESSAGE THAT OTHER STATES
NEED TO HEAR FROM CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S WHY S. B. EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE IS SO IMPORTANT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT KEEPING HOLLYWOOD
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE IT WAS BORN
AND WHERE IT BELONGS.
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING OUR MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS AND SUPPORTING OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES SOMETHING THAT
ALL OF US CAN GET BEHIND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NAMES BLOOM MR ACOSTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE AS SOMEONE WHO GREW
UP IN.
WITH THE FATHER AND THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND SOME
OF HIS WORK IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERA KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS
INDUSTRY IS AND I WAS PROUD TO
BE.
A PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
SOMEONE WHO WORKED VERY HARD ON
THIS ALONG WITH MANY MY
COLLEAGUES HERE FROM OFFICES AND
YEAH CENTURY CITY UP HERE TO THE
CAPITOL.
AND ALSO ON THE MOVIE RANCHES
AND AND SOUND STUDIOS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO CALIFORNIA AND LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM A FOR BIG THERE I
LIKE TO SEE THE OVERALL CLIMB IN
CALIFORNIA.
A BUSINESS CLIMATE BE IMPROVED
BUT THIS IS A GREAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND IT IS A
VITAL INDUSTRY.
I AND I WILL NO LONGER HAVE TO
SEE --
BEFORE OBVIOUSLY FOR AS I WILL
NO LONGER HAVE TO SEE --
SOME OF MY CONSTITUENTS LEAVE
AND GO TO OTHER STATES FOR A
THREE TO SIX MONTHS AT A TIME OR
LONGER AND ACTUALLY HAVING A A
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON THEIR
FAMILIES.
I REALLY ENCOURAGE AYE AYE VOTE
HERE AND I REALLY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THIS BODY TO A MAKE
THE SOME TAX CREDITS PERMANENT --
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE KEEPING
AN INDUSTRY THAT WAS STARTED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND THRIVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA HERE IN THE
IN THE GOLD STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY WHICH CASA MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET ON THE FILM TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED FOR OUR FILM INDUSTRY
IN THIS MEASURE WILL PROTECT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
JOBS.
ADDITIONALLY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
FILMS TELEVISION SHOWS AND OUR
WORKFORCE REFLECTED ADVERSITY OF
OUR STATE BOTH ON AND OFF THE
SCREEN THE API CAUCUS PRAISES
THE INCLUSION.
OF THE DIVERSITY LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL AND WE ARE PROUD TO
HAVE PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN ITS
INCLUSION WE ALSO THANK
SPECIFICALLY THE MAJORITY LEADER.
I FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND HIS
ADVOCACY FOR THIS IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE MEASURE.
WE HOPE AND BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THAT IT WILL ALSO CREATE SUPPORT
FOR UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
IN THE FILM INDUSTRY ADVERSITY
OPPORTUNITY AND INCLUSION MATTER
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA MITCH
MATHIS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
AS THE REPRESENTATIVE WHO
REPRESENTS ALL.
THE BACKLOG OF HOLLYWOOD JUST
ABOUT THE DREAM.
HOURS NORTH EAST IN INYO COUNTY.
ON WERE ALSO THE HOME OF THE
LONE PINE FILM.
HISTORY MUSEUM WHERE A LOT OF
OUR OLD WESTERNS WERE FILMED IN
STILL SEVERAL MOVIES TO THIS DAY.
ARM I STAND IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL [inaudible] EIGHT SEVENTY
ONE ON THIS DEFINITELY FILM
INDUSTRY AND I ENCOURAGE ALL YOU
LA FOLKS TO GET UP TO THE
EASTERN SIERRAS.
AND CHECK OUT THE ALABAMA HILLS
AND WHAT WE HAVE TO OFFER OUT
THERE SO COME OUT TO THE BACK
LOT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT IMITATIONS
MATHIS [inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
DALLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO STAND.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BUT I ALSO
WANTED.
JUST MAYBE EXPAND I'VE HEARD A
LOT OF THEM.
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW IT DRIVES THE
ECONOMY AND HOW TAX CREDITS FOR
BUSINESSES WORK.
AND THATYOU KNOW LAST WEEK I
SHARED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY
BUSINESS AND THE THINGS I'M
FACING.
AND THE DECISIONS I HAVE TO MAKE
IN MY LITTLE SMALL BUSINESS.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT COULD USE A TAX BREAK.
AND IT WILL DRIVE OUR ECONOMY
JUST LIKE IT DOES FOR THE FILM
INDUSTRY.
HOW ABOUT THE PERSON WHO COOKED
FOOD IN A RESTAURANT?
HOW ABOUT THE PERSON YOU CUT
YOUR HAIR?
THERE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY NEED A TAX BREAK.
TO SO I URGE OF YES VOTE ON THIS.
AND I URGE OF MAYBE A BIPARTISAN.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE OTHER
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA IT IS
GETTING MORE DIFFICULT TO
PERATE A BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
DUE TO THE REGULATIONS AND TAXES
THAT WE HAVE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE KNOW ONE YOU LOWER TAXES AND
REGULATIONS THAT BUSINESSES
ACTUALLY PROVIDE MORE MONEY TO
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN THEY GROW.
SO AYE URGING AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL AND I URGE PARTICIPATION IN
HELPING OTHER BUSINESSES GET TAX
BREAKS [inaudible]
TO MR THURMOND.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR ME TO ASK.
I'M SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF SB A SEVENTY ONE AND WOOD%
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THOSE THAT
YOU'VE HEARD THAT THIS TAX
CREDIT WILL SUPPORT --
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
THAT SUPPORTS OUR ENTIRE STATE
AYE EVEN THOSE OF US WHO
REPRESENT DISTRICTS THAT ARE
VERY FAR.
FROM LOS ANGELES AYE IT WILL
ALLOW BUSINESSES TO STATE OUR
STATE I WANT TO MAKE ON THE FILM
INDUSTRY ARE ALL ABOUT
CALIFORNIA.
NOW IT WILL ALLOW FOR THE
BUSINESSES THAT SUPPLY THAT
SECTOR -- TO
BENEFIT AND PROSPER IT WILL DO
WHAT TAX CREDITS ARE INTENDED TO
DO.
PORTANTINO'S THREE IS THAT
ACTUALLY CREATE JOBS I'M DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S WORK IN THIS AREA ON IT
FOR BRINGING TOGETHER VERY BROAD%
COALITION.
THAT LOOK AT ALL THINGS
PATHWAY THAT WILL ALLOW --
INDIVIDUALS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRAIN
AND LEARN AND TO EARN A IN THIS
SECTOR FOR ALL THOSE REASONS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THEY GIVE MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AYE AYE THEY HATE TO BE THE ONE
TO RAIN ON THE PARADE --
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT THAT.
I DON'T THINK THIS INDUSTRY IS
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT --
IT DOES BRING JOBS THEN
OPPORTUNITIES IT HAS FOR A VERY
LONG TIME --
I JUST HAVE A HARD TIME STANDING
HERE AND AND DOING US A SPECIAL
TAX BREAK. FOR ONE INDUSTRY --
WHEN YOU'VE?
WHEN YOU'VE BEEN TOLD MANY TIMES
IN THIS BODY FROM OTHERS ABOUT
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE REALLY
SUFFERING --
ONE THAT I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
IS THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY WHEN
I PLEAD WITH YOU.
ABOUT REGULATIONS AND LAWS THAT
THAT YOU ARE PASS THERE ARE
SYSTEMATICALLY DESTROYING THAT
INDUSTRY.
WHEN I PLEAD WITH YOU ABOUT THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY THAT
CREATES?
A VERY GOOD PAINT JOBS IN THE
STATE.
THAT NOW CALIFORNIA'S LAST PLACE
IN MANUFACTURING JOBS CREATED --
SO IN THE FACE OF ALL THOSE
THINGS TO NOW GIVE A TAX CREDIT.
TO AN INDUSTRY THAT'S DOING
PRETTY WELL GUYS.
THAT'S MAKING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
RIGHT AND A TAX CREDIT THAT
DOESN'T REALLY TRICKLE DOWN
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WHO'S GONNA BENEFIT FROM THIS.
BIG COMPANIES PRODUCTION
COMPANIES EXECUTIVES.
THAT'S WHO BENEFITS FROM THIS
THAT'S WHO GETS TO PUT THAT ON
THEIR TAX.
ON THEIR TAX RETURNS.
NOW SOMEONE COMMENTED ON MY
FACEBOOK --
WHEN I WAS ONE OF THE ONLY ONES
TO VOTE NO ON THIS --
YOU KNOW THEY MIGHT BRING
HALLMARK MOVIES UP THERE.
TO YOU KNOW YUBA CITY IN.
SMALL MARYSVILLE IN SMALL TOWNS
OF THE DISTRICT WHY HAVEN'T SEEN
A WHOLE LOT OF HOLLYWOOD
ATTENTION.
UP OF MY DISTRICT --
AND I GOTTA TELL YA I I JUST
DON'T SEE ALL THESE BIG BENEFITS
US A LOT OF BIG BENEFITS GOING
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE THE VERY RICH.
IN THIS STATE.
AND THEN TAD BUT I WOULD SAY
INSULT TO INJURY TO SAY OH YEAH
AND WE'RE TAKING CARE OF THEIR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PROBLEM.
BECAUSE WE'RE TO MAKE HIM FILE
THEIR POLICY.
WHEN THEY APPLY FOR THE TAX
CREDIT IS NOT THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE A POLICY?
IS THAT YOU ACTUALLY ENFORCE IT.
AND THE PROBLEM IS.
THEY DON'T ENFORCE THEY'VE HAD
POLICIES ON THE BOOKS AND THE
REASON Y. PEOPLE.
WERE SCARED TO COME FOR THE WHAT
REASON WHY PEOPLE.
DIDN'T SPEAK IN OUR FILE FINALLY
DID SPEAK.
IS BECAUSE HE SINGS ONE OF FORCE
IN BECAUSE THEY WERE BRUSHED
UNDER THE TABLE SO I DON'T THINK
THIS DOES ANYTHING.
YEAH MY MAKE YOU PAT YOURSELF ON
THE BACK AND SAY WE'RE DOING
SOME BUT I THINK IT TOTALLY
MISSES [inaudible]
ME -- TOO
AND TO SAIL YEAH THIS IS WERE
REALLY GET REFORM OF THESE
PEOPLE.
WE GOT POLICIES.
TO WE HAVE FOR SOME.
THAT'S THE QUESTION WE SHOULD BE
ASKING OURSELVES AND SO LOOK I
JUST CAN'T SIT HERE AND AND JOIN
IN THE PARADE.
TO OFFER THIS BIG THAT TAX BREAK.
NOW NGUYEN MANY OTHER INDUSTRIES
IN THIS DAY AND I SAID ARE
SUFFERING OR OR UNDER THE BURDEN.
THE HUGE REGULATORY BURDEN OF
THE STATE.
AND MANY PEOPLE ARE WITHOUT JOBS.
IT WOULD BE VERY GOOD PAIN THAT
WOULD HELP THEM HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE LIFESTYLE.
WHY DO WE SINGLE OUT ONE
INDUSTRY WHAT BECAUSE
POLITICALLY POWERFUL?
BECAUSE IT'S POPULAR.
I WOULD ASK --
THAT PEOPLE WHAT CHECK THEIR
CONSCIENCE ON THIS ONE IS THIS
REALLY GOOD NOT.
ARGENEAU VOTE THANK YOU.
ISSUE AS AREA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING ON
THIS BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY DONE
QUITE A BIT OF WORK AND THOSE OF
US WHO.
HAVE THE HIGHEST MEMBERSHIP IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY OF
AYE OUT SEE OR EMPLOYEES A STAND
TO BENEFIT GREATLY AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE WHAT THIS BODY
IS DOING BECAUSE THOSE ARE
EMPLOYEES.
WHO ARE GONNA STAY IN THEIR
DISTRICTS ORGANISED NAME THEIR
HOMES THEY'RE NOT GONNA LEAVE TO
GO TO ENGLAND?
THEY'RE NOT GONNA LEAVE TO GO TO
CANADA OR THIRTY SIX OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE BEEN OFFERING
SOME KIND OF A CREDIT.
AND I WOULD WELCOME THE
GENTLEMAN FROM A YUBA CITY. TO
COME AND PAY A VISIT AND KNOCK
ON DOORS AND MY DISTRICT AND
MEET SOME OF THE FOLKS WHOSE
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN TORN.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS.
I AND NOW THAT WON'T BE THE CASE
THAT HASN'T BEEN THE CASE EVER
SINCE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THESE
TAX CREDITS.
SO UP WHILE I VALUE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING AND I WISH THAT.
WE CAN --
OFFER PROTECTIONS TO MANY
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES --
I THINK.
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
HELPING PROTECT MANY FAMILIES
AND OUR STATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TOO
WAS NOT GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS
ISSUE --
BECAUSE SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MADE SUCH COMPELLING POINTS --
BUT I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT
SOUND THE FIFTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT IS HOME TO THREE
PRODUCTION STUDIOS --
WHO HAVE SUFFERED?
WE ARE ALSO HOME TO WEST LA
COLLEGE WHICH HAS THE ONLY
CAREER.
TECHNICAL CURRICULUM THAT ALLOWS
FOR FOLKS MOSTLY WORKING POOR
AND WORKING CLASS STUDENTS. TO
ATTEND AND GAIN TRAINING THAT
WILL THEN ALLOW THEM TO GO INTO
BELOW THE LINE JOBS ACTUALLY
WORKING ON FILM AND TELEVISION
SETS HELPING TO MAKE THEM HAPPEN.
IF THAT'S DOING GRIPS ARE
LIGHTING NICK CETERA.
AND I HAVE SEEN THE DIRECT AND
INDIRECT ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT
THIS INDUSTRY HAS ON COMMUNITIES
ON NEIGHBORHOODS AND ON FAMILIES
AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORKING.
ON LOCATION ON FILMS IT'S FLORES.
IT'S TAYLOR'S ITS FOLKS DOING
COSTUMING IT'S SPOKE PREPARING
FOOD ITS MUSICIANS ITS SPECIAL
EFFECTS PEOPLE ITS DRIVERS IT
HAS A REAL.
TANGIBLE DIRECT IMPACT.
THAT IS A RIPPLE OF FACT FOR SO
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
I ALSO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
OTHER WAYS TO SUPPORT OTHER
INDUSTRIES AND SECTORS THAT ARE
EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO THIS GREAT
STATE BUT I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
ON S. B..
EIGHT SEVEN ONE MISS WALDRON.
YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS --
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW USED TO WORK
FOR NBC.
SPORTS IN NEW YORK.
AND I CAN TESTIFY THAT.
THE INDUSTRY REALLY HELPS REPEL
ALMOST LIKE A RIPPLE EFFECT.
HUNDREDS EVEN THOUSANDS OF OTHER
ANCILLARY BUSINESSES THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT WHEN THE
FILM CREW COMES IN OR
PRODUCTIONS OF DON THE BOOKING
HOTEL ROOMS ARE EATING IN
RESTAURANTS.
THEIR ORDERING SANDWICHES OUT
CONSTANTLY THOSE CONSULATE FOOD
BEING BROUGHT IN.
FOLKS ARE EMPLOYING LOCAL LABOR
WHETHER THEY'RE BEAUTICIANS ARE
INTERNAL SALON WORKERS THERE'S
TONS OF OTHER JOBS.
TO TAXICABS AND UBER ISN'T ALL
KINDS OF TRANSPORTATION
EVERYTHING IS IMPACTED
POSITIVELY.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ONE THIS
LEGISLATURE --
CREATED THE TAX CREDIT FOR THE
INDUSTRY --
WE HAVE STARTED TO SEE A LOT OF
JOBS COMING BACK TO CALIFORNIA
SINCE JULY OF TWENTY FIFTEEN
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN CREDITS.
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED. TO THE
HUNDRED FIFTY FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTIONS. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION PUT
OUT BUT ON THE OTHER HAND. FIVE
POINT NINE BILLION IN REVENUE
HAS COME BACK TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THAT'S
MONEY WELL EARNED.
AND AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE [inaudible]
RETAIN.
YOU MAY CLOSE HEWISH.
I THINK YOU SPEAK I THINK THEY
ARE MY ALL MY COLLEAGUES --
Q. MOVIE RAISED ALL THE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES WHY WE SHOULD.
SUPPORT THIS VERY IMPORTANT
VIBRANT INDUSTRY AND WHO
ULTIMATELY REALLY BENEFITS I
THINK THE ULTIMATE OFFICIALS ARE
REALLY.
US AS CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THEY WERE STAYING AT WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
ZARA VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI THE VOTE EYES
SEVENTY SIX KNOWS ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER S. B. FIVE TEN FORTY
EIGHT ALLEN FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY FIX
FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE TO NOTICE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THE JUNE
TWENTY SEVENTH HEARING.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
STERN PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND
SB ONE THOUSAND LADA PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
ALSO GRANTED.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY THREE IN SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THOSE BILLS ARE A. B. EIGHTEEN
NO WAIT EIGHTEEN OH NINE
EIGHTEEN TEN AND EIGHTEEN ELEVEN
AND IS WATER THAT WE OPPOSE THAT
MOTION.
MS WALTERS WITH HOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
THIS IS A RULE SUSPENSION MISTER
CALDERON MOVES A SECOND BY
MISTER BONTA MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MISS WALDRON AND
VOTE.
MISS WALDRON A NO VOTE THIS
TAKES FORTY ONE ON THE RULES.
CLERK WILL.
CLERK WILL CLOSE TO ROLL.
I FIFTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY THREE THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO MOVE TO TAKE UP [inaudible]
A. B.. EIGHTEEN NO WAY.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL IF YOU KNOW EIGHT
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
NATURALLY AND EDUCATION FINANCE
MAKING APPROPRIATIONS ARE FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TING YOU MAY OPEN
THINKING BUT SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTEEN AWAY IS OUR EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL.
MAKES CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT THE
K. TWELVE IN EARLY EDUCATION
BUDGET ACTIONS.
ALLOCATES THREE POINT SIX SEVEN
BILLION AN ONGOING PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING TO FURTHER
IMPLEMENT THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
PROVIDES A ONE BILLION DOLLARS
OF ONE TIME DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY A FUNNY TO ALLOCATE FROM
LOW PERFORMING STUDENTS.
BASED ON PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS
IN THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND
MATH.
ALSO PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION AN ONGOING PROP
NINETY FUNDING FOR THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
SENATE GRANT ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION.
INCLUDES AND ALSO INCLUDES A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY FUNDING FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED.
K. TWELVE COMMUNITY CRIER
TECHNOLOGICALLY XIN PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE
COMMUNICABLE ITS STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM.
THEY ALSO DEDICATE A HUNDRED
MILLION A ONE TIME NON PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
FACILITIES GROUNDS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL.
AGENCIES TEMPERAMENT FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THINGS TAKE MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN NO EIGHT I
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL HAVE
A VERY POSITIVE AND MEANINGFUL
IMPACT ON K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
IN CALIFORNIA IT WILL FULLY FUND
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA IT WILL DEVOTE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CAREER AND TECHNICAL EDUCATION
AND K. TWELVE SETTINGS --
IT WILL ESTABLISH A GRANT
ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEM OF TEACHER
SHORTAGES PARTICULARLY IN
TECHNICAL FIELDS BUT WHAT I WANT
TO TELL YOU ABOUT MY MOST OF MY
FAVORITE APPROPRIATIONS BILL.
IS IT WILL ESTABLISH THE KIDS
CODE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS A
GRANT PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
TEACHING KIDS INCAPABLE SETTINGS.
HOW TO PROGRAM COMPUTERS AND AS
A RECOVERING COMPUTER PROGRAMMER
WHO HAS WRITTEN MILLIONS OF
LINES OF CODE HIS CAREER AND AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS INTERVIEWED AND
HIRED HUNDREDS OF COMPUTER
PROGRAMMERS?
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE SKILLS
ARE SORELY LACKING IN TODAY'S
YOUTH THIS BILL IS WORTHY OF
SUPPORT AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
TAKE A MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER
LACKEY.
HIS THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS
ALL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE IT INCLUDES.
MANY PROVISIONS THAT ARE
BENEFICIAL TO IMPROVING OUR
STATE'S EDUCATION SYSTEM.
I AM HOWEVER DISHEARTENED TO SEE
THAT THERE'S NOT BEEN FUNDING.
INCLUDED FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THIS OF BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE
SECURING EQUALIZED FUNDS SO THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE PROPERLY FUNDED.
THIS IS A DESERVING POPULATION
THAT IS MEANT TO BENEFIT FROM
THE GOVERNMENTAL SAFETY NET.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO KEEP KICKING
THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD ON THIS
ISSUE.
WE NEED TO QUICKLY ACT TO FIND A
RESOLUTION OF THIS PROBLEM.
YOUR KILEY EUREKA.
I MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO MUST SAY
I AM VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS RESULTED IN
THE REMOVAL OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT. FOR OUR
SPECIAL EDUCATION SYSTEM.
THIS WAS TO BE A VITAL STEP.
TOWARDS PROVIDING EQUITY FOR
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS TO
ASSURE THAT THEY CAN RECEIVE THE
EDUCATION THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED.
TO AND THAT THEY DESERVE.
THE TRUTH IS THAT WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED EDUCATION FUNDING IN
RECENT YEARS.
SPECIAL EDUCATION HAS NOT BEEN A
PRIORITY.
OVER SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
K. TWELVE STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS ARE STILL NOT GETTING
NEARLY THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED.
CURRENT SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING RATES AND HERE TO AN
ARCHAIC FORMULA THE PRESENT
PRODUCES VAST INEQUITIES.
IN SOME REGIONS THE ADA BASE
RATES ARE AS HIGH AS FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY SIX DOLLARS WHILE
IN OTHER DISTRICTS THERE IS A
LOW AS FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
DOLLARS.
FURTHER THE GROWTH OF THESE
RATES IS TIED OVERALL STUDENT
ENROLLMENT NOT TO THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
I SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS RISE
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL STATE SUPPORT
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS FACE MORE
MORE PRESSURE ON THEIR GENERAL
FUND BUDGETS THAT'S WHY ARE SO
PLEASANT SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
ASKED URGENTLY. FOR OUR HELP.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO DELIVER AND FOR THE SAKE
OF SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA I HOPE THAT IN
THE FUTURE WE CAN DO BETTER.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY MR
MCCARTY YOUR RECORDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THIS
IS THE PRODUCT OF OUR BIPARTISAN
WORK ON ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER --
TWO PROUD TO HAVE A LOT OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT WE DISCUSSED IN
THE SUB COMMITTEE PROCESS
INCLUDE IN THE FINAL VERSION.
A RECORD AMOUNT OF MONIES SPENT
FOR A PUBLIC SCHOOLS OVER THREE
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS IN
LCF THAT MONEY.
GOING OUT A THAT THE LOCAL
DISTRICT LEVEL TO FOCUS ON
PRIORITIES INCLUDING ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION I WILL NOTE THAT THIS
IS NOT.
ARE A PERFECT OF FUNDING SALUTE.
LONG BEACH AND I HELD A HEARING
TALKING ABOUT SOME POTENTIAL
REMEDIES THERE WEREN'T ALL
INCLUDE THE FINAL BUDGET WHICH
WE DO HAVE A A SET ASIDE THIS
BUDGET DEALING WITH TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS HELPING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOCUSED ON A
TEACHER COR.
TEACHER CORPS PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOR SPECIAL ED.
I EDUCATE SPECIAL EDUCATORS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS I WE HAVE.
A BIPARTISAN APPROPRIATION YEAR
FOR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
AND WE GOT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED THE JANUARY BUDGET
I CONSIDER THAT A BIG BIG WIN.
OVER ALL IT'S A SOLID BUDGET FOR
EDUCATION I WILL NOTE.
GOOD NUMBERS GOOD BUDGET BUT
WE'RE STILL IN THE LOW FORTIES
IN PER PUPIL FUNDING IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE NOT DONE
WITH THEIR WORK AND WILL BE BACK
NEXT YEAR THANK YOU.
THEY ARE AS PARTY SCENE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM MISTER TANG YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE --
MY COLLEAGUES AND ALL THE ROBUST
DEBATE ABOUT SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
MENTIONED AS CHAIR OF OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WE PORT IN
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
WE KNOW THAT IT'S ACTUALLY ONE
OF OUR PRIORITIES AS AN ASSEMBLY
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE UNABLE
TO REACH AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR OR THE SENATE.
JUST MEANS THAT WALL HAVE TO BE
MORE UNIFIED NEXT YEAR TO GO GET
THAT MONEY FOR THAT EQUALIZATION.
AYE AM WITHOUT RESPECT FOR HOUSE
RIVAL FOR AB EIGHTEEN AWAY.
THEY WISH CHIANG CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WIZARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLLING TIED ABOUT I
SEVENTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE AND
SEVENTY SEVEN ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM TO TAKE UP
THE FOLLOWING BILL WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE CURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS THAT BILL IS AB.
EIGHTEEN TWELVE AND MISS WALDRON.
WE OPPOSE THAT MS WALTERS
WITHHOLDING.
THIS A PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS
MISTER CALDERON MOVES THE ROLL
SUSPENSION A SECOND BY MISTER
BONTA.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR DIVERT
HIM MISS WALDRON A NO VOTE.
THIS IS ON THE ROLL SUSPENSION
TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE I SHOULD FOR KNOWS.
TWENTY FIVE THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
AB.
EIGHTEEN OH NINE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE.
CARPOOL RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN OH NINE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY TO EDUCATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR TO TAKE
KEPT ME DELETE ALL RELATE TO THE
BUDGET.
MISTER CHENEY MAKE AN OPEN.
THANK YOU BUT SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTEEN OH NINE IS OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
TRAILER BILL --
THE BILL'S MAJOR PROVISIONS ARE
THE CREATION OF A NEW ONLINE
COLLEGE BY COURSES AND PROGRAMS
AT THE TO SHORT TERM.
INDUSTRY VALUED CERTIFICATES ARE
CREATES A NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING FORMULA WHICH PROVIDES
COLLEGES FUNDING FOR ENROLLMENT
OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS A
SPECIFIC OUTCOMES.
IT ALSO EXPANDS FINANCIAL AID
FOR ELIGIBLE COMMUNICATE
LISTINGS BY PROVIDING UP TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
COVER NON TUITION COSTS.
IT ALSO PROVIDES COMMITTEE
COLLEGES FUNDING TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HUNGER.
BASIC NEEDS SUPPORT CAMPUS
VETERANS RESOURCES CENTER
SUPPORT PROGRAMS FOR CURRENTLY
INFORMALLY ACROSS RATED STUDENTS
PROVIDES LEGAL SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS STUDENTS.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
AND TRAINING IN SUPPORT OF OUR
PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE HOURS I
WOULD THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I DON'T.
TAKING MISTING MR ACOSTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU TO MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS PSALM I I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY BUT I
BELIEVE IT MAKES A LOT OF
POSITIVE CHANGES.
I DO HOWEVER HAVE A CONCERN.
FORMULA OF THE NEW FORMULA DOES
NOT PROPERLY SPORT COLLEGES LIKE
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS IN MY
DISTRICT.
I WHO PARTNER WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES TO OFFER ON GOING
TRAINING THROUGH THE
INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE AGREEMENTS
TAUGHT TO CURRENT POLICE
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS.
OF THE OUTCOME MEASURES IN THE
NEW FORM FORMING A NEW FORMULA
SUCH AS DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE
COMPLETION MILESTONES AND LOW
INCOME STUDENT PROVISIONS FAILED
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE SERVICE
AGREEMENTS.
PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES ARE
GENERALLY NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL AID SINCE THEY WORK
FULL TIME NOR WILL THEY BE
EARNING DEGREES OR CERTIFICATES.
SO COLLEGES OFFERING THIS
TRAINING WILL ONLY BE PAID UNDER
THE ENROLLMENT PORTION OF THE
FORMULA.
WOULD FULLY IMPLEMENTED THAT'S
JUST 60% OF WHAT THEY NOW
RECEIVE TO OFFER THIS TRAINING
THAT HELPS ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THE JUST
THE FORMULASO THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY TRAINING OFFERED THROUGH
THE INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE
AGREEMENTS.
IS EXCLUDED FROM THE FORMULA AS
WAS ALREADY DONE FOR CERTAIN NON
CREDIT COURSES AS A SAID I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE AND HOPE
WE CAN ENSURE IMPORTANT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S.
LIKE THEY ARE TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THEY MISSED ACOSTA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
SEARCHING YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'D
LIKE -- TO
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS
FROM SANTA CLARITA WELL
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL BE WATCHING THIS
NEW FUNDING FORMULA VERY VERY
CLOSELY SEEING HOW IT ACTUALLY.
IMPACTS EACH AND EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
BOTH POSITIVELY AND NEGATIVELY
IN BE EVALUATING THAT --
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US RIGHT
NOW.
CLICK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROWLAND HIGH THAT I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BABY EIGHTEEN TEN WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR PARADE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TEN BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC HEALTH MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET [inaudible]
MR TAKE.
THEY MIGHT SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN
TENANTS ARE HEALTH TRAILER BILL.
ON THIS REFLECTS THE FIRST STEPS
TOWARD OUR HEALTH CARE GOALS
ESTABLISHES THE COUNCIL ON
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS. TO
DEVELOP A PLAN TO ACHIEVE
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE AND ACCESS
CARE THREE UNIFIED HEALTH CARE
FINANCING SYSTEM.
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA PERRANCE SEE DATABASE.
THE CLERK HEALTH CARE COST
INFORMATION CREE TRANSPARENCY IN
FOREIGN POLICY DECISIONS AND
REDUCE DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
CARE.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE TO DEVELOP AND PROVIDE
OPTIONS TO LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR.
ON PROVIDING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS TO HELP THEM
ACCESS AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE THROUGH THE EXCHANGE.
IT ALSO ELIMINATES CAPS ON THE
WEB OF TREATMENT FOR BREAST AND
CERVICAL CANCER THROUGH THE
BREAST.
THE CIVIL CANCER TREATMENT
PROGRAM.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT
[inaudible]
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION DAY BE EIGHTEEN
TEN THIS TRAILER BILL
ESTABLISHES THE COUNCIL ON
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
THE STATED INTENT OF THIS
COUNCIL IS TO ESTABLISH
UNIVERSAL FINANCING FOR
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA WHEN I
ASK THE QUESTION OF WHETHER NOT
THIS WAS LEADING UP TO SINGLE
PAYER HEALTHCARE.
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE I WAS TOLD
THAT YES IT WAS AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S VERY INAPPROPRIATE AS WE
ALL KNOW SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE
HAS BEEN AN ISSUE OF INTENSE
DEBATE.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE AND I THINK
IT IS INAPPROPRIATE TO ESTABLISH
A BOARD TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION WHILE THE LEGISLATURE
IS STILL DEBATING IT LET ALONE
HAVING ACTED I URGE A NO VOTE
[inaudible]
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU WISH A VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER OB I I ALSO RISE
AND OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG
BEAR YOU KNOW I WAS EXCITED TO
SEE SOME --
IMPORTANT CHANGES THAT WOULD
HEALTH WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE THAT
ARE ON MEDI CAL THAT WAS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS HOWEVER --
I WAS VERY VERY DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE THAT THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
ISSUES THAT ARE PUT TOGETHER
THIS BILL AND BOND ALONG WITH
THE POSITIVE THERE IS A WHOLE
LOT A NEGATIVE THIS BILL APPOINT
APPOINT ONE OR TWO OUT.
I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT THIS
BILL WOULD DIVERT MANY CRIMINALS
INCLUDING SOME WHO ARE ACCUSED
OF SERIOUS FELONIES FOR EVER
STANDING TRIAL.
AND THEREFORE WILL BYPASS MANY
VICTIMS RIGHT TO RECEIVE
COMPENSATION OR DECEIVE THEIR
VICTIM MYERS VICTIMIZER STAND
TRIAL.
OUT FURTHER MORE THIS BILL DOES
AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED --
MAKE A GIANT LEAP THAT EVERY CAL.
RATHER THAN RESEARCH HOW WE CAN
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO THE
REMAINING CALIFORNIANS WHO DON'T
HAVE HEALTH CARE.
COVERAGE THAT HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE THIS BILL ASSUMES
CALIFORNIA WILL ESTABLISH A
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
RESEARCH AND STUDY IS GOOD BUT
RESEARCH THAT IS NOT OPEN TO
BETTER OUTCOMES IS BIASED AND
DAMAGING TO OUR STATE.
I CAN'T VOTE FOR A STUDY.
I CAN'T VOTE FOR A TO STUDY HOW
THE STATE CAN BEST PUT THOUSANDS
OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS OUT OF
JOBS I CAN'T GO FOR STUDY.
HOW HOW TO PREVENT A PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM KEEPING THE COVERAGE
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE AND I
CAN'T GO TO STUDY HOW WE SHOULD
GO ABOUT BURNING TAXPAYERS WITH
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS?
OF NEW TAXES OUR STATE DESERVES
BETTER I REQUEST A NO VOTE AND
LET'S GET THE INDIVIDUAL
ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL RIGHT
PIECE BY PIECE.
SEPARATE SO WE CAN VOTE ON THEM
SEPARATELY NOT AS ONE BIG BILL
PACKET SUCH AS THIS AND COURAGE
AND NO VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE I DON'T.
HURTING YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
I THINK YOU'RE SPEAKER AGAIN IT
MAY BE.
EIGHTEEN TEN IS ABOUT FINDING A
PATH TOWARD UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE OF THIS IS A GOAL THAT
WE WOULD ALL LIKE WE BELIEVE
THAT -- IT'S
BETTER FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA TO
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE IT'S CHEAPER IN THE
LONG RUN.
IT'S BETTER FOR OUR COUNTY
SYSTEMS IN OUR WHOLE ENTIRE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM NOW BELIEVE
WILL HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES.
AGAIN ALL THIS CANCEL DOES IS TO
TAKE A LOOK AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
SOME OF THOSE OPTIONS ARE I KNOW
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN
STUDYING FOR YEARS.
IT ALLOWS THE STATE ACTUALLY TO
DEVELOP SOME PLANS IN A PATHWAY
FORWARD.
OUT WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US
RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE WRONG TIVER AT EYES FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS.
TWENTY FOUR SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS THIS IS AB.
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN ELEVEN BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
EXPLAINED HUMAN SERVICES MAKING
A PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TECH.
I THINK IN WHICH SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN ELEVENS ARE HUMAN
SERVICES TRAILER BILL.
AS YOU KNOW WITH ONE OF FIVE
CALIFORNIANS LIVING IN POVERTY
IN MANY OF THEM IN DEEP POVERTY --
THIS TRAILER BILL WAS
ESTABLISHED TO REALLY FIGHT IN A
TACKLE SOME OF THOSE VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUES.
IT SETS A GOAL OF NO CHILD IN
DEEP POVERTY STATING STARTING
WITH THE 10% GRANT.
INCREASE STARTING IN APRIL FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN STEPS AND
ENSUING YEARS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND FUTURE BUDGET
SO THAT ONE DAY NO CHILD WILL
LIVE UNDER 50% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
REYES THE PER DAY VOUCHER AMOUNT
FOR THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS A FIVE DOLLARS TO
EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS.
CREATES AND COMMENCES THE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING INITIATIVE
PROVIDING CHILD DEVELOPMENT
PARROTING SUPPORT TO PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS WITH CHILDREN.
UNDER TWO YEARS OF AGE REVERSES
THE CASH SHALL MAKING FORMERLY
EXCLUDED INDIVIDUALS ELIGIBLE.
CALIFORNIA BENEFITS AND HOLDING
HER MISS CURRENT CASES. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND ONE
TIME FUNDS IT ALSO RAISES THE
ELIGIBILITY AGE FOR CHAFEE
GRANTS FOR FOSTER YOUTH UNTIL
AGE. TWENTY SIX IN FOR OLDER
YOUTH EMERGENCY SHELTERS IN
GROUP HOMES PROMOTES DE
ESCALATION TROMBONE FOR PRACTICE.
LUKE REDUCE LONG FORCED
PERIPHERALS IT ALSO CREATES THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM FOR VULNERABLE
ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULTS TO
MAINTAIN THEM.
IN THEIR HOMES AND HOUSING
ARRANGEMENTS AND LASTLY IT
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA FRUIT
AND VEGETABLE EBT PILOT. TO
ALLOW FOR DOUBLING OF CAL FRESH
BENEFITS IN A WIDER RANGE OF
GROCERY AND RETAIL LOCATIONS
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS EXISTING STATE
LAW ESTABLISHES A WELFARE TO
WORK REQUIREMENT FOR CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS HOWEVER IF A
RECIPIENT.
IS A STUDENT ENROLLED IN A
DEGREE PRINTING PROGRAMMER
CERTIFICATE GRANTING PROGRAM
THAT WILL ENHANCE THEIR
EMPLOYABILITY.
EXISTING STATE LAW ALLOWS THEM
TO COUNT THE CLASSROOM HOURS
SPENT IN PURSUIT OF THAT DEGREE
OF THAT CERTIFICATE TO WARDS
THAT WORK REQUIREMENT WHICH I
THINK IS VERY APPROPRIATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS TRAILER BILL
EXTENDS THE HAD TO SELF REPORTED
INDEPENDENT HOME STUDY TIME.
THAT IS NOTORIOUSLY DIFFICULT.
TO TO POLICE AND I FEAR THAT
IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO GREATER
POTENTIAL FOR FRAUD AND ABUSE IN
THE CAL WORK SYSTEM.
MOREOVER IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE
TO INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY THE SOFT
REPORTED STUDY TIME IT WOULD
ALSO BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR COUNTIES
TO CONTEST THAT SOFT REPORTED
STUDY TIME IF THEY FELT.
THAT THE RECIPIENT WAS NOT BEING
ACCURATE FOR THAT REASON I MUST
URGE NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
RETAIN WILL FOREGO THE CLOTHES
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
AND MEMBERS THIS IS A BE
EIGHTEEN AND TWELVE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TWELVE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY A PUBLIC SAFETY MAKING
A PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TECH [inaudible]
THE GIRL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN TWELVE IS OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL REQUIRES CDC ARE TO
CREE SAY CREATE A FACILITY PLAN
TO MAXIMIZE LONG TERM FACILITY
SAVINGS.
PROVIDES CALIFORNIA IDEAS FOR
YOUTH RELEASED FROM THEIR
JURISDICTION.
ESTABLISHES THE YOUTH
REINVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM TO
DIVERT YOUTH INCLUDING NATIVE
AMERICAN YOUTH WHO COMMIT STATUS
AND OTHER LOW LEVEL OFFENSES
WITH PROGRAMMING IN SUPPORT IN
LIEU OF ARREST AND DETENTION.
I THINK CREATES INNOVATION AND
EFFICIENT SQUARE PROGRAM FOR LOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING IN THE
AREA OF USE OF FORCE DE
ESCALATION OFFICER WELLNESS
IMPLICIT BIAS CULTURE DIVERSITY
AND COMMUNITY POLICING.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB EIGHTEEN TWELVE EXISTING
STATE LAW ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AND
CORRECTIONS TO PETITION THE
COURT. FOR A REDUCTION IN THE
SENSE OF INMATE IF AN ERROR WAS
MADE DURING THE SENTENCING
PROCESS FOR THIS TRAILER BILL
WOULD EXTEND OUT AUTHORITY. FOR
THE CDC ARE TO OUR REQUEST THE
REDUCTION IN SENTENCE FOR THINGS
THAT OCCUR POST CONVICTION WHICH
ARE ABOUT THINGS LIKE
REHABILITATION OR GOOD BEHAVIOR --
THIS IS A VIOLATION OF THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS BETWEEN THE
COURT SYSTEM AND THE CDC ARE THE
COURT SYSTEM.
IS CHARGED WITH THE IMPOSITION
OF SENTENCE IS IN THE INTEREST
OF JUSTICE AND THE CDC ARE IS
CHARGED WITH THE CARRYING OUT OF
THOSE SENSES.
I AM CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL
WOULD GIVE THE CDC ARE TOO MUCH
LATITUDE IN REQUESTING THEIR
SONS REDUCTION FOR THOSE INMATES
AND THEREFORE I URGE A NO VOTE.
DAVIS OBERNOLTE MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHTEEN TWELVE OBJECTS
LEGISLATURE REALLY SHOULD BE
PROUD.
WE DID THAT TAKEN A BOLD STEP TO
STOPS LOCKING UP OUR CHILDREN IS
START INVESTING IN YOUR FUTURE
BY CREATING TO YOU REINVESTMENT
FUND.
BOTH HOUSES IN IN A BIPARTISAN
FASHION APPROVED THIRTY SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET THAT WOULD IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES OF VULNERABLE YOUTH
POPULATIONS TO YOU DIVERSION
PROGRAMS.
CRAIG INTRON INFORMED COMMUNITY
AND HEALTH BASED INTERVENTIONS
IN LIEU OF ARRESTS.
ATTENTION AND INCARCERATION WILL
START TO DISMANTLE THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
OVER ONE MILLION WILL GO TO
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES FOR YOU
DIVERSION PROGRAMS 10% REDUCTION
IN JUVENILE MISDEMEANORS OR
STATUS.
OFFENSE ARREST AN ARREST WILL
SAVE CALIFORNIA APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
STATUS OFFENSES SUCH AS RUNNING
AWAY FROM HOME.
BREAKING CURFEW AND GETTING INTO
SCHOOL FIGHTS.
SHOULD NOT BE A CRIME WE SEND
SOMEONE TO JAIL INVESTING AND
YOU'VE DIVERSION CAN RESULT IN
APPROXIMATELY. EIGHT BILLION IN
SAVINGS TO THE STATE IF WE PLACE
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND YOUTH.
AND DIVERSION VERSUS JUVENILE
HALL DIVERSION HAS PROVEN HAS
PROVEN TO WORK AND WE NEED TO
STOP LOCKING UP OUR KIDS AND
START INVESTING IN THE FUTURE.
SPECULATE AT THREE I'VE.
THINGS JONES SAWYER MISS
MELINDA'S.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLLER TIE THAT I
FIFTY KNOWS TWENTY FOUR SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WHILE WE ARE WAITING WE
DO HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT COUNTER.
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACTUALLY THE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE NO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MEMBERS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME BUT I
SEVENTY NINE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AND CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATE BILL.
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE I SEVENTY
NINE NO ZERO CYNICAL FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX I SEVENTY NINE NO
ZERO SIMPLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
I SEVENTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION. TO THREE BY
SEVENTY NINE KNOW ZERO AND
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
SIX I SEVENTY NINE KNOWS
.
ZERO MEMBERS QUORUM CALL IS IN
PLACE.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS RATED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
QUORUM CALL IS IN PLACE.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE TURNING IN THE MEMORY MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS ORTEGA
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO REQUEST THAT THIS BODY
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF RUSSELL
BLEW IT.
RUSSELL WAS THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF HIS SPERRY AYE HE WAS A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE HE HAD A
LONG HISTORY IN PUBLIC SERVICE
STARTED THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL BALDWIN PARK HE WENT ON
TO SERVE TWO TERMS AS MAYOR AND
THE CITY OF --
IT'S A BETTER READ.
CITY OF SAN GABRIEL VALLEY --
HE WAS --
ELECTED TWICE TO THE CITY
COUNCIL THE CITY OF ITS BERIA
SERVED EIGHT YEARS THERE IN TWO
TERMS AS MAYOR --
HE WAS ALSO A SMALL BUSINESSMAN
HE STARTED A FLOORING COMPANY.
AND WAS INVOLVED IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OVER TWO THOUSAND
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA HE WAS ACTIVE IN THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
ARISING TO BE PRESIDENT OF A
LOCAL CHAPTER BUT ABOVE ALL HE
WAS THE HUMANITARIAN.
I HE GAVE HIS CELLPHONE OUT
EVERYWHERE THAT HE WENT AND EVEN
THOUGH HE WAS A STRONGLY
OPINIONATED PERSON.
HE WAS MORE INTERESTED IN
HEARING THE OPINIONS OF HIS
CONSTITUENTS ALWAYS WILLING TO
DISCUSS THEIR PROBLEMS WITH THEM
ALWAYS WILLING TO REFORM HIS
VIEWS AND HIS OPINIONS BASED ON
WHAT HE HEARD BACK FROM THEM.
I CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT IN
ADDITION TO BEING DEEPLY
RESPECTED.
BY THE PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT
HESPERIA HE WAS BELOVED.
WHICH I THINK IS MORE THAN YOU
CAN SAY AS MUCH AS YOU CAN SAY
FOR ANY OF US SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY.
HE WAS A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE AND
HE WILL BE SORELY MISSED.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
IF YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO ADJOURN
MEMORY OF ME SO BAD.
THE LAST GUESTS WHO WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO IN THE CITY
OF EL MONTE CALIFORNIA.
PRIOR TO LOCATING TO INDIO.
CALIFORNIA.
SHE ATTENDED WESTSIDE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND THEN LONDON BE
JOHNSON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHERE
SHE JOINED.
COULD A COURSE.
SHE ALSO WAS A STUDENT AT IN
YOUR MIDDLE SCHOOL WHERE SHE
PLAYED THE TRUMPET AND BECAME AN
ACTIVIST.
IS ALSO TRYING TO ALWAYS BE
INVOLVED IN HELPING OTHERS.
IS WHERE SHE BECAME VERY.
VERY INTERESTED IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF ANY HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND JOIN THE UNITED STATES ARMY
RESERVE AT THE AGE OF NINETEEN
SEVEN WANTED TO PURSUE HER OWN
CAREER.
AND DREAMS SO SHE DECIDED TO
ENROLL IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ACADEMY AT THE COLLEGE OF THE
DESERT AND FINISHED HER TRAINING
AT THE BEN PARK PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAINING SENATOR.
SENATE.
CENTER IN RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA.
WAS SHE PURSUED HER EDUCATION
SHE WORK THAT AWAITS HIS
REHABILITATION CENTER AND LATER
TELECARE WHERE SHE WORKED WITH
THE DIVERSE POPULATION.
INVOLVING MENTAL HEALTH.
GEN BECAME A PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICER AT THE FANTASY SPRINGS
RESORT CASINO.
IN JULY TWO THOUSAND STEEN.
FILTER DREAM AND WAS HIRED AS A
POLICE OFFICER WITH THE CITY OF
INDIO.
PROP HER LIFE FEASIBLE TRAINED
IN TAEKWONDO PLAYED THE GUITAR.
ROAD DIRT BIKES AND LEFT THE
CAMP WITH HER BELOVED HUSKY FLEX
SHE WAS ALSO A FREQUENT BLOOD
DONOR WITH LIFESTREAM THERE
LOCALLY IN THE VALLEY.
IT'S KIND SMART INDEPENDENT AND
ALWAYS HELPING OTHERS.
IS SURVIVED BY HER PARENTS AND
HER SIBLINGS NIECES NEPHEWS AND
EXTENDED FAMILY IN CALIFORNIA
BEDROOM.
AND MEDICAL. TO THE FAMILY.
AND THE OFFICERS THAT WORK SIDE
BY SIDE WITH THEIR OF THE END UP
DE.
I SAY ME THE CONDOLENCES OF THIS
BODY.
AND THE THOUSANDS OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS OF THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WHO MOURN HER LOSS --
BRING THAT THIS BRINGS COMFORT.
AND MAY OUR PRAYERS --
BRING AN EASE THE PAIN OF THEIR
LOSS I WANTED TO JUST TO READ.
A POST THAT WAS OPPOSED TO BUY
HER COLLEAGUES THE IN YOUR
POLICE DEPARTMENT ON JUNE FIRST.
IN MEMORY OF ISABELLE IZZY
VELASQUEZ TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD.
OFFICER VELAZQUEZ WAS HIRED WITH
THE IN YOUR POLICE DEPARTMENT ON
JULY SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND STING.
AFTER A BRIEF BUT BRAVE BATTLE
WITH A RARE FORM OF LUNG CANCER
OFFICER VELASQUEZ PASSED AWAY ON
MAY THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE ENTIRE
IN YOUR POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
MOURNING THE LOSS.
THEIR SISTER IN BLUE.
WE ARE SHAKEN TO ARE CORE TO
LEARN OVER UNEXPECTED PASSING
OFFICER VELAZQUEZ WAS A
BEAUTIFUL SOUL.
WITH AN INFECTIOUS SMILE.
HER IN UPD FAMILY WILL MISS HER
GREATLY.
IN A MESSAGE HER RED IZZY.
BUT YOU MAY HAVE LOST THE BATTLE
WE CARRY ON IN YOUR NAME TO
FIGHT THE GOOD FIGHT.
WE WILL REMAIN FOREVER.
W. FORTY FIFTY FIVE STRONG.
WE HAVE THE WATCH.
FROM HERE AS YOU HOLD THE LINE
FROM ABOVE.
UNTIL WE SEE YOU AGAIN MAYOR
SMILE NEVER FADE IN OUR HEART.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA.
MISTER LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ARE RISE TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY
OF TIM KLINE.
A DEDICATED TEACHER PONGAL HIGH
SCHOOL [inaudible]
WHO PASSED?
AFTER A CLIMBING ACCIDENT IN
YOSEMITE.
TIM WAS A HIGHLY RESPECTED
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR THE STUDENTS IN PALM
DEL AFTER TERRIFYING.
SCHOOL SHOOTING.
TIM WAS A SKILLED CLIMBER AND
EVEN HOLDS THE WORLD RECORD. FOR
THE FASTEST CLIMATE QUIBBLE IT
TO THE HEIGHT OF MOUNT EVEREST.
ON A CLIMBING WALL WHICH HE
PERFORMED IN NINE HOURS TWENTY
SIX MINUTES AND FIFTEEN SECONDS.
HE EXHIBITED ALL THE MOST
TREASURED HUMAN QUALITIES
INCLUDING COMPASSION.
OPTIMISM AND KINDNESS.
HE SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JJ AND
HIS TWO CHILDREN LEVI AND JACK.
I ONE HONOR KIM'S LIFE OF
CELEBRATE HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND APPRECIATE THE LEGACY OF HIS
COMPASSION.
WHICH HE LEAVES BEHIND.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN THE
JOURNEY GOODNESS MEMORY TODAY.
A PASSING ALONG OUR CONDOLENCES
TO HIS FAMILY [inaudible]
LACKEY.
FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
CHAIRMAN.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AYE RISE THE JOURNEY IN
THE MEMORY OF FORMER BIGGEST A
MAYOR MEDICATION HOW.
THE PASSED AWAY ON JUNE
FOURTEENTH AT THE AGE NINETY ONE
MARY KAY SHOW WAS A TRAILBLAZER
AND A ROLE MODEL.
SHE WAS THE FIRST WOMAN TO SERVE
AS MAYOR BIGGEST FILM AND THE
SECOND WOMAN ELECTED TO THE
CURRENT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
YOU SERVED THREE TERMS.
DURING HER TIME ELECTED OFFICE
SHE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OCCUR QUE
RESIDENTS.
IT'S ARE MOST MEMORABLE
CONGRESSMAN SAYS MAYOR INCLUDE
INCLUDED CREATING A CITY FLAG
ESTABLISHING INITIATIVES TO BE
TO FIRE CITY.
AS A SUPERVISOR SHE WORKED TO
ENSURE THAT TAXPAYERS INTERESTS
WERE ALWAYS PROTECTED.
AND WORK IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION
TO SOLVE THE COUNTY'S MOST
PRESSING ISSUES.
EDITION TO OUR SERVICE IN PUBLIC
OFFICE SHE WAS A NEWSPAPER
REPORTER AND ACTIVISTS AT LEGAL
CALMNESS AND RESPECTED STATES
WOMAN.
SHE WAS AN ICON AND I CAN
PROUDLY SAY THAT KERN COUNTY IS
A BETTER PLACE BECAUSE OF YOUR
SERVICE.
SHE WAS ALSO DEDICATED WIFE AND
MOTHER WHO FAITHFULLY SERVED
ALONGSIDE HER HUSBAND JOE SHELL
DURING HIS TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SHE LIVED LIFE TO THE FULLEST
AND I WILL MISS MY FRIEND AND
HER CONTAGIOUS SMILE.
OUR PRAYERS GO OUT TO A FAMILY
AND ALL THOSE WITH THE PRIVILEGE
OF CALLING HER FRIEND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN JOINING IN
MEMORY OF KERN COUNTY ICON MAKE
A SHOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PHAM MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL OUR QUEST WHICH JOURNAL
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN.
THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS WHILE WE AWAIT FURTHER
ACTION.
QUORUM CALL REMAINS IN PLACE.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
[inaudible]
TUESDAY [inaudible]
JUNE.
NINETEEN CHECK IN SESSION THIS
IS THE SESSION SCHEDULE MEMBERS
TUESDAY JUNE NINETEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION.
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTIETH CHECK
IN SESSION.
THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY FIRST FLOOR
SESSION.
IS AT NINE AM
WE ARE BACK ON THE
THIRD READING FILE.
THIS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY THIS IS A ARE.
TWO THIRTY EIGHT MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MISTER
KALRA THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULT BEE'S
AWARENESS MONTH.
WHO'S YOUR KALRA YOU MAY OPEN ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MIX MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ACR TO THIRTY EIGHT
PROCLAIMS THAT ACKNOWLEDGES THE
MONTH OF JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS ELDER
AND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
OUTER INDEPENDENT ADULTS MAY BE
IMPACTED BY PHYSICAL MENTAL
PHARMACEUTICAL OR MEDICAL
INFLUENCES.
A TWO THOUSAND NINE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE STUDY FOUND
THAT 11% OF ELDERS REPORTED
EXPERIENCING AT LEAST ONE FORM
OF MISTREATMENT.
INCLUDING EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL OR
SEXUAL MISTREATMENT OR NEGLECT
IN THE PAST YEAR AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT IN THE DECADE SINCE THOSE
NUMBERS ONLY GOTTEN WORSE.
CURRENT ESTIMATES SUGGEST ONLY
ONE IN FOURTEEN CASES OF ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSES
REPORTED INCLUDING FEWER THAN
ONE IN TWENTY FIVE INCIDENTS OF
FINANCIAL ABUSE.
SUBTLE INDICATORS THAT A BIT
VIEWS MAY BE OCCURRING CLUED
BRUISES.
A CHANGING ALERTNESS UNUSUAL
DEPRESSION SUDDEN CHANGES IN
FINANCIAL SITUATIONS AND
STRAINED OR TENSE.
RELATIONSHIPS.
RECOGNIZING THESE SIGNS IS THE
FIRST STEP.
TOWARD PREVENTION OF ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE.
ELDERS INDEPENDENT ADULTS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO LIVE SAFELY WITH BY
THEIR IN THEIR HOMES OR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
AND TO ENJOY AN OPTIMUM QUALITY
OF LIFE WALL FREE FROM ABUSE AND
ALL FORMS OF INJUSTICE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF JUNE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS ELDER
AND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
CONSISTENT WITH THE WORLD ELDER
ABUSE AWARENESS DAY OF JUNE
FIFTEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE MASS FOR THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
MISTER KALRA ARE YOU ASKING THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
CLAIRE CLUB THE ROLE.
AMBITIOUS IS CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
CLARK WELL CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY
FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED TO IT OUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I OPPOSE SAME DAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINETEEN THIS IS A SEA ARE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN BY MISTER SALAS THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS RELATIVE TO
PORTUGUESE NATIONAL HERITAGE
MONTH.
MISTER SALAS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE RING UP ACR ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN DECLARES THE MONTH OF JUNE.
AS PORTUGUESE NATIONAL HERITAGE
MONTH RECOGNITION OF THEIR
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE ENTIRE WORLD EVERY YEAR
THOUSANDS OF FESTIVALS PASSED US.
ARE HELD IN HONOR OF THE HOLY
SPIRIT OF PORTUGAL'S NATIONAL
DAY WHICH IS JUNE TENTH.
MEMBERS LAST I LAST WEEK YOU MAY
HAVE NOTICED THAT THE PRIME
MINISTER JOINED US.
HERE THE CHAMBERS AND IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND HE WAS
HERE DOING A TOUR THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
RECOGNIZING PORTUGUESE UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
ESPECIALLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE SEE A LOT OF NOT ONLY
IN LIKE THE DAIRY INDUSTRY IN
THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY.
BUT IN ALL INDUSTRIES LAWYERS
DOCTORS I THEIR FABRIC OF OUR
COMMUNITY THEIR FABRIC OF
CALIFORNIA AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THAT'S FOR THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
AND MR LIVING.
THANK YOU MUCH SO MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THE PUSH YOU
HAVE A LONG HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE'VE HEARD FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD.
IN MARIN COUNTY THE PORTUGUESE
IMMIGRANTS OF THE FIRST ONES
ARRIVED IN THE EARLY EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS ON WHALING SHIPS AND
DURING THE NINETEEN HUNDREDS
THEY SETTLED IN SOUTHERN RENDON
TRANSFORMED OUR LOCAL DAIRY
INDUSTRY.
THE SAUSALITO PORTUGUESE
CULTURAL CENTER CONTINUES REMAIN
ACTIVE ENSURES PORTUGUESE
HERITAGE WITH THE GREATER
COMMUNITY AS YOU HEARD.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF PORTUGAL
WAS HERE IN CALIFORNIA HE
ACTUALLY CAME. TO SAUSALITO LAST
WEEK. TO DEDICATE A NEW PLAZA
PAID WITH FIFTEEN TIMES OF
PORTUGUESE STONE TO CELEBRATE.
THE SISTER CITY RELATIONSHIP
SAUSALITO HAS WITH KID KASH
PORTUGAL THE HISTORY AND CULTURE
THE POULTRY PORTUGUESE COMMUNITY
IS AN AMAZING PART AROUND STATES
DIVERSITY AND HISTORY I HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN US IN VOTING FOR ACR.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER LEVINE.
MISS ADHERE CURRY I'M SORRY I
THOUGHT THAT WAS YOUR PIN WHEEL
IS YOUR MICROPHONE THAT WAS ME
SAYING I AM THE ONLY PORTUGUESE
ON THIS FLOOR.
TODAY PROBABLY AND I WANT YOU TO
SUPPORT ACR BUT ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
WE HOPE TO US START OF
PORTUGUESE CAUCUS HERE AS WELL
AS MAYBE DO SOME EDUCATIONAL
TOURS THAT.
POLY MANY OF YOUR BO --
EXCITED ABOUT MY FATHER WAS BORN
SMOTHERS BORN IN THE AZORES.
AND TO SANTA --
WE JUST RECENTLY CELEBRATED I
GUESS OF THE INDIVIDUAL ANY OF
THE LAST OF MY FAMILY THE AG WE
OURS.
IN LATE.
AND I JUST WANT TO I THINK --
OUR REPRESENTATIVE FROM --
TO LETTER BAKERSFIELD FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER SALAS YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I APPRECIATE ALL MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS OBVIOUSLY THE
PORTUGUESE COMMUNITY IS A VERY
INTEGRAL PART OF WHAT WE DO HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND MOVING OUR
STATE FORWARD.
I'M IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE
TO GO TO A FAST ARE ENJOY SOME
SALT.
AND I WELCOME YOU GUYS COME AND
JOIN ME IN MY DISTRICT OR
ANYWHERE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE ASKED FOR THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR BECAUSE THERE'S MEMBERS
MISTER SALAS IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CLERK
WILL OVER THE ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON A C. ARE. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE TO ROLL.
THERE ARE SEVENTY EIGHT CAO
AUTHORS ADDED ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
HI OPPOSE SAME DAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB SEVEN TEN BY DOCTOR WOULD.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER WOULD ACTUALLY
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE IT'S KINDA
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
DOCTOR WOULD THEY MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS EPILEPSY IS A MEDICAL
CONDITION TO PRODUCE THE
SEIZURES AFFECTING A VARIETY OF
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL FUNCTIONS.
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN TWENTY SIX
AMERICANS WILL DEVELOP ABSOLUTE
EPILEPSY AT SOME POINT IN THEIR
LIFETIME.
THE US FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION IS CURRENTLY
REVIEWING AT LEAST ONE
CANNABIDIOL DERIVED THERAPY THAT
SHOWS PROMISE FOR THE TREATMENT
OF EPILEPSY.
AB SEVEN TEN WOULD IMMEDIATELY
DOWN SCHEDULE CANNABIDIOL BASED
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE APPROVED
FOR MEDICAL USE BY THE U. S.
FOOD AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION.
DESPERATELY ILL ADULTS AND
CHILDREN EPILEPSY WHO ARE IN
URGENT NEED OF ADDITIONAL
TREATMENT OPTIONS WILL HAVE
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO THIS
BREAKTHROUGH MEDICATION.
AS SOON AS THE FDA RESCHEDULED
THE THERAPY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO.
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LOVED THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
TO SATISFY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE OR DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROADS HAD ABOUT I SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY.
I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE
BILL SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS
MEMBERS I HAVE --
ANNOUNCEMENT.
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING UPON ADJOURNMENT
A ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM.
FOUR FOUR FOUR IN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
UNDER MISTER FRASIER'S
LEADERSHIP WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM FORTY TO GO.
TO ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER DALLI MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY.
JUNE TWENTY FIRST AND I AM IN
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED